WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO THE APRIL TWENTY
FIRST HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE. TO
START I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STAFF THAT MADE POSSIBLE OUR
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAFE
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS.
TO THAT END ON THEY'LL SHARE A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF OUR HEARING TODAY REGARDING-PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY AND TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION.
DUE TO THE CURRENT STATE HOME
ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EVERYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING.
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A. EXPIATE OF SPACING IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WITH LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH MY. PLEASE FOR
DIALING WITNESSES. WILL BE
USING A MODERATOR TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH-
WITNESSES CAN TO. ON A- THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BELT. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
EIGHT NINE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO AND HOW. IN ADDITION.
WITNESSES WHAT OUR- TO ONE OF
OUR REMOTE. TEST STATIONS
LOCATE ON THE CAPITAL FOR.
TESTING IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TEST OF FROM IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES. MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND CAN ALSO
ASK QUESTIONS OF THESE
WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FOR THE STREAM
FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT. AND I JUST LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
WE'RE USING THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS TODAY ARE WE-
BOB KARP. OKAY NOT THE ONES IN
THE PARK THANK YOU. VIDEO RIGHT
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOMS. SIX
OKAY ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN IN
THE CAPITAL THANK YOU. OKAY AND
I JUST LIKE TO SPEAK A MOMENT
ABOUT DISRUPTIONS- I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS SIMPLY
HAS ENCOUNTERED REPEATED
DISRUPTIONS OF ITS PROCEEDINGS
IN RECENT YEARS AND THIS IS
RUCTIONS HAVE INCREASED THIS
YEAR. RECENT DISRUPTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT PROCEEDINGS HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT THE U. S.
CAPITOL NESSET NECESSITATE
CONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS.
AND RULES AGAINST DISRUPTION.
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING
IS PROHIBITED. IF DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY HE WILL
BE WARNED YOU'LL BE REMOVED FOR
THE HEARING ROOM FROM THE
HEARING ROOM BY THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS. OR YOU WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE CALL. ONE
TWIST SEVEN QUORUM WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TWELVE OF
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE COMPANY AND WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY. PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE LIMITING TESTIMONY
TO TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MAY ADD ON BY STATE
THEIR NAMES AND AFFILIATIONS.
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES- ON
CONSENT. SB SIX FORTY COOLEY AB
FIVE NINETY TWO FRIEDMAN AB
THREE NINETY SIX GABRIEL A. B.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN GABRIEL AB
SIX SIXTY FIVE. GARCIA AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN MULLIN AB TWO TWO SIX
RAMEAU'S. AB EIGHT SEVEN THREE
RAMOS AB TEN FIFTY FIVE RAMOS
AB THREE NINETY THREE REYES AB
TWO SIXTY STONE AND AB TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE STONE. OKAY
SECRETARY TO HAVE A QUORUM. YES
PLEASE TAKE A WALDRON I DAVIES.
ARAMBULA CHOI HERE GIPSON STONE
FILOPODIA WORK. THANK YOU OKAY
CAN WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT COUNTERS. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALDERON AYE
CALDERON AYE DAVIES DAVIES I'D
ARAMBULA. CHOI CHOI I GIPSON.
STONE STONE ARAMBULA HUDA THE
LITTLE I MORE. OKAY THANK YOU
WILL THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY THE WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO GO A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF ORDER TODAY- WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH A
SUPPLEMENT STYLE YOU READY TO
PROCEED PRESENT YOUR BILL.
YOU'RE WELCOME. FOR BEING
WILLING TO TAKE THIS OUT OF
ORDER BRIEFLY THIS IS AB EIGHT
OH EIGHT WHICH IS A CHILDREN'S
CRISIS CONTINUUM. PILOT PROGRAM
OPEN WORKING ON THE CONTINUE OF
CARE REFORM SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN. AND WHAT HAS
ARISEN REALLY SENSE THAT IN
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED AND HAVE NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED. INSURING
THAT WE HAVE CAPACITY WITHIN
THE STATE TO DEAL WITH KIDS
WITH ALL LEVEL OF NEEDS. AND
UNTIL LAST DECEMBER THERE WAS A
SMALL COHORT BUT IMPORTANT
COHORT THAT WE WERE SENDING OUT
OF STATE. AND BECAUSE THE SS
NEEDED TO DE CERTIFY ALL OF
THOSE OUT OF STATE PROGRAMS
THEY WERE BROUGHT BACK AND I
WANT TO THANK DSS AND THE
COUNTY'S. OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
FOR WORKING TO MAKE SURE THOSE
KIDS WERE. APPROPRIATELY PLACED.
BUT THAT A FORTY STILL EXISTS
AND POTENTIALLY THAT NEED.
MIGHT ARISE AGAIN AND I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE A HARD LOOK. AT
INSURING WE HAVE THAT CAPACITY
IN CALIFORNIA. TO DEAL WITH ALL
THOSE KIDS. PRECLUDING THE NEED
TO SEND THEM OUT OF STATE WHICH
IS SOMETHING. FROM MY
STANDPOINT I THINK WE SHOULD
NOT BE DOING. ANY MORE. HELLO
SO WHAT AB EIGHT AWAIT DOES IS
IT CREATES. A MORE INTENSIVE
SET OF POTENTIAL SERVICES. HEY
CHRIS STABILIZATION UNIT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY AND
APPROPRIATELY STEP DOWN THE
SERVICES AS THE KIDS NEEDS ARE
MET WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE CHILDREN. AND
THAT THEY ARE GETTING THEIR
NEEDS MET WHATEVER THEY ARE.
AND SOMETIMES WE CLASSIFY KIDS
IS HIGH NEED. AND NOT
NECESSARILY ABLE TO ADDRESS
ACTUALLY THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
PIECE THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE. SO
THE TO. OUR YOUTH ARE GETTING
IN THERE NEEDS MET. AND WE HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT CAN RSPOND.
ADEQUATELY THROUGHOUT ALL
COUNTIES AND ADEQUATELY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THAT'S
WHAT AB EIGHT OH EIGHT IS
ABOUT. AND WE ARE STILL.
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON IT
AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
WITH THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT OUR
APPROACH IS CORRECT. AND THAT
WE ARE REALLY BUILDIN THAT
SYSTEM FOR THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN AND I CANNOT
UNDERSCORE. HOW IMPORTANT THAT
PARTICULAR COMPONENT ULTIMATELY
IS. WITH MERE KATHY CENTRELINK
FROM THE CHILD WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND CAN
BERWICK FROM SENECA ERIC. IT IS
FAMILY OF A- WHICH IS ONE OF
THE- THAT THAT DOES HELP
PROVIDE. CARE FOR OUR CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE TAKE THE STEPS THAT WE CLOSE
RECOGNIZED AND CLOSE THE GAPS.
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S AB EIGHT AWAIT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER. I OP DO WE HAVE-
FIRST WITH WITNESS ON THE LINE
MR BERWICK. PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
BURKE. THANK YOU YOU CHAIR CALL
MA'AM OF THE- FOR CONSIDERING
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I'M CAN DEREK AND
I'M THE CEO AND FOUNDER OF
TECHNICAL FAMILY OF AGENCIES
AND SENECA SEEKS TO CREATE A
CONTINUE OF CARE TO HELP
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO THEIR
MOST DIFFICULT TIMES AND WE TRY
TO DO THAT- REGARDLESS OF THE
LEVEL OF NEED- AND MORE THAN
FIVE YEARS AGO WE HELPED TO
CONVENE- STAKEHOLDER AROUND THE
STATE. TO TALK ABOUT A GAP IN
THAT SYSTEM THAT GAP WAS FOR
THOSE YOUNG THAT BERRY SMALL
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAD
THE GREATEST NEED AND THAT WERE
STRUGGLING AND WE IDENTIFIED AS
A AS A REAL PROBLEM- THE FACT
IT THE DEAD IN ORDER TO THE
JUNK WE WERE SENDING THEM OUT
OF HELLO COM CARE FACILITY
INSTEAD OF HAVING WE NEEDED IN
THE STATE TO SERVE UP. SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING BOTH- THAT
COMMITTEE IT'S THE CHILD CAN
MIDDLE HEALTH- CAN AND WOULD
STAY COLD AROUND THE STATE IDEA
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING THIS
WE'VE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
IN THE STATE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF WRAPAROUND
MANY YEARS AGO TO SEE IF YOU
ARE MORE RECENTLY AND WE'VE WE
WERE GETTING VERY CLOSE TO
HAVING A SYSTEM THAT CAN HELP
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THROUGH
THEIR MOST DIFFICULT TIMES WITH
WRAPAROUND AT THE CENTER OF
THAT. AND MORE RECENTLY USING A
SYSTEM OF EXPEDITED TRANSITION
THAT HELPED TO BRING FAR MORE
KIDS HOME RATHER THAN MOVING
THEM INTO CONTINUE CONGREGATE
SETTINGS THAT BEING SAID
THERE'S A GAP IN CALIFORNIA
THAT GAP IS REALLY- A
SIGNIFICANT AND IT KEEPS YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM STAYING HERE AND
BEING SERVED IN THE MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED SETTING SO THAT
THEY CAN BENEFIT THEM THE MOST-
THIS BILL SIXTY DEMONSTRATE
THAT WE CAN DO THAT THAT WE CAN
DO IT WELL THAT WE- ACROSS THE
STATE. AND COMPLETE THE WORK
THAT WE STARTED WITH C. C. R.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BERWICK. OPERATE CAN YOU
THE LINE FOR THE WIND WITNESS.
MRS MADAN. THANK YOU. THANK
MADAM CHAIR NOW CAP SOUTHERLY
MCDONNELL WITH THE COUNTY WATER
AT THE- SHE GOT THE PLEASED TO
BE A SPONSOR OF AB ONLY YOU
KNOW EIGHT WITH ATTACKS AND THE-
RATE OFFICER AT THIS OF POWER.
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OUT THE
PURPOSE OF THE TRIP OF AB IN A
WAY THEIR TURN GAP IN OUR
SERVER INTO SHE CAN POSH CARE
SPECIFIC BECAUSE OF EXPERIENCE
VERY THINK. TRAUMA I HAVE CIGNA
SERVER NEEDS FOR MANY YEARS EVE
CREATING THE CAN OF CARE FOR.
COUNTIES OF STRUGGLE TO MEET
THE OF THE GRAY OF. A HIGH NEED
YOU STEVIE HAVE STRENGTH.
SERVICE HEIGHTEN FOR THAT THAT
THAT ARE YOU WITHOUT THE
SERVICE THE RATE YOU CAN PAY
SEATED BDA TIED WITHOUT THIS BY
SPONSORING EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
CARRIED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
COOLEY WHO'S ALSO CO AUTHORED
AB IT AWAY. AMONG OTHER THINGS
THAT BILL REQUIRED THE STATE TO
PERFORM A GAP ANALYSIS OF
SERVICES FOR USE WITH THESE
MORE COMPLEX NEEDS AND THEN
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS CHECK
OUT THAT MEET. THAT ANALYSIS
HAS NOT YET BEEN COMPLETED BY
THE DEADLINE IN THE LEGISLATION
IT'S BEHIND SCHEDULE WALDRON
PROGRESS NOW WE HAVE QUITE
FRANKLY LOT TIME AND LOST
GROUND AND OUR CHILDREN. AND
YOUTH HAVE BORNE THE RESULTS OF
THAT. WE COUNTY SIX. A THE
YEARS THIS IS A FOR WHICH MORE.
AND MORE COPPER. SERVICES ARE
NEEDED NOW HELP IDENTIFY AND
BUILD UNDERSTANDING. AND
BILDERBERG RESILIENCE SO THEY
COULD EITHER AVOID CONGREGATE
PLACEMENT ALTOGETHER OR IF IT
IS WARRANTED UPFRONT. ENSURING
THAT IN THE SHORT TERM SO WE
CAN GET THEM BACK INTO FAMILY
LIFE SETTING AS WE WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY DONE WITH MANY OF
THEIR PEERS. IMPORTANTLY EIGHTY
ELITE WITH FILL THAT HOLE IN
THE HIGHER END OF THE
CONTINUUM. BUT SERVICES THAT
ARE DEVELOPING AVAILABLE WITH
IN CALIFORNIA. SO THAT ARE
COUNTY AGENCIES ARE NOT FORCED
TO RELY ON OUT OF STATE
OPTIONS. TO CARE FOR THE
EASIEST. WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OTHERS THAT THIS IS
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO BE DOING.
WE NEED THOSE SERVICES HERE AND
THE PRODUCT PLACEMENT CHOICES
TO EXIST HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
A WAY THAT THEY DO NOT EXIST
TODAY. FINALLY THE BILL ALSO
PRIORITIZES INTENSIVE TREATMENT
FOLLOWED QUICKLY BY A STEP DOWN
TO INTENSIVE BUT HOME BASED
SERVICES. THE GOAL IS NOT TO
SIMPLY CREATE A CONGREGATE CARE
OPTIONS FOR YOUTH AND THEN JUST
LEAVE THEM THERE SH THE GOAL IS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE A TO CONTINUE
ON FOR ALL OF THE WE- ARE.
STILL WE STRIVE TO SUPPORT THEM
IN HOME BASED SETTINGS. AND WE
FILL THE GAPS WE KNOW EXCEPT
FOR THE RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER
OF YEARS. FOR HIM THAT
CONTINUING CALL SORT TODAY.
FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE OUR
AYE VOTE ON. THAT MEASURE AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK OKAY DO WE
HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SO I'M SORRY I GOT A-
WE HAVE DIVISIONAL SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. OPERATOR. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT
AND AB EIGHT OH EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GO
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
IN THE PLACE YOU BACK IN QUEUE
SO AGAIN FOR SUPPORT ON AB
EIGHT OH EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWO TEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DIFFERENT
KIDNEY FAN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION- OR
CALCUTTA. IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT AWAIT THANK YOU. OPERATOR
TO HAVE ANY ELSE ON THE ON THE
QUEUE YES EXCUSE ME I WAS MUTED
I'M I APOLOGIZE- TO TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
SHARE MEMBERS TRIPLE GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA VERY
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE- AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT
ON AB EIGHT OH EIGHT. THANK YOU
TO NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DIVINE AND I
REPRESENT THE BEST PART
PALMDALE AND A SUPPORT. EIGHTY
THIRTY ONE. AND IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL LINES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO QUEUE UP TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT IN AB EIGHT OH EIGHT
ARE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE. ONE NINETY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES FANTASQUE
ON BEHALF OF S. E. I. U.
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND MEDICARE THERE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR I DO
WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
NEED SAME NINE DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT IN
THE- VIDEO WITNESS ROOM. AND
NOW OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITE. OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
QUEUE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR APP- OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT OH EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME CHAU
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION FOR BILL
AB EIGHT OH EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU MA'AM I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION IN THE VIDEO WITNESS
RIGHT NOW OKAY- ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. FROM THE
COMMITTEE. NO OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WILL KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS APPROACH.
AND THEIR CONCERNS REALLY ARE
WELL TAKEN WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THIS AND
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE DO SET
UP SOMETHING THAT IS
APPROPRIATE WORLD FAMILIAR WITH
THE S. T. R. T. P.'S IT WAS SET
UP UNDER THE C. C. R. THOSE ARE
THEORETICALLY MEANT TO TAKE ALL
KIDS. REALITY IS THAT THEY
DON'T SO WE NEED TO BECAUSE
THAT'S THE GAP THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CLOSE HERE. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING THIS IN A WAY THAT SERVES
THE NEEDS OF THE KIDS. SO BY
STOPPING AT LEAST NOW THE- HOW
TO STAY PLACEMENTS WHICH THIS
BILL DOESN'T SAY BUT IT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE
TO DO TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT ANYMORE BUT- BUT
THEN MAKING SURE WE'RE BUILDING
THIS CAPACITY. IN THE STATE IN
A LOGICAL WAY. DSS IS GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THAT GAP
ANALYSIS AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS SO WE SHOULD BE
GETTING A LOT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED
TO TAKE CONTROL OF SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIGURE OUT OF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND SO GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE CALDERON. I CALDERON
I'D DAVIES. DAVIES I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I'D CHOI. CHOI HI
GIPSON GIPSON AYE STONE AYE
STONE AYE FILOPODIA. AYE LORD
LORD HI THE VOTED EIGHT TO ZERO
THANK YOU. OKAY I NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM ASSEMBLYMEN BENNETT
WHICH LIKE TO PRESENT ON.
EIGHTY NINE FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- AND MEMBERS EIGHTY
NINE FORTY ONE WOULD ESTABLISH
A GRANT PROGRAM- IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF KIM COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT TO
FUND THE CREATION OF A
FARMWORKER RESOURCE PROGRAM. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- THE VENTURA
COUNTY SUPERVISORS WORKING WITH
FARMWORKER ORGANIZATIONS AND
WITH THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
CREATED THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
FARMWORKER RESOURCE PROGRAM AND-
FOR THE FOR THE FARMWORKERS
INVENTOR COUNTY- I WAS HONORED
TO BE A PART OF THAT. THE
CENTER WAS NEEDED FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS FARMWORKERS WERE
STRUGGLING EXCUSE ME. THANK
YOU- FARMWORKERS ARE STRUGGLING
WITH WHERE TO TURN TO GET
ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS ABOUT
LABOR ISSUES GOVERNMENT AND
NONPROFIT PROGRAMS THAT THEY
MAY QUALIFY TO GET GET
ASSISTANCE FROM AND GENERAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOUSING
EDUCATION AND HEALTH OPTIONS.
ON THE DAY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES TO
DATE THE FARMWORKER RESOURCE
PROGRAM AND VENTURA COUNTY HAS
ASSISTED OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
FARMWORKERS WITH VARIOUS TYPES
OF ISSUES INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT
LABOR LAWS. HOUSING IMMIGRATION
FINANCIAL AND FOOD ASSISTANCE
AND MANY OTHER INQUIRE RES- IT
WAS ESSENTIAL DURING COVERT TO
HAVE ALREADY ESTABLISHED A
TRUSTED RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
COUNTY GOVERNMENT- AND
FARMWORKERS AS WE TRIED TO GET
BOTH TESTING AND- VACCINATION
PROGRAMS MOVING- AB NINE FORTY
ONE WOULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA TO CREATE SIMILAR
PROGRAMS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS WHO
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT ASSISTANCE
OUR GROWERS AND LANDOWNERS IN
THE AG INDUSTRY. IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO ALSO SUPPORT
FARMWORKERS DURING THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE
HAVE A ONE WITNESS KELLY
BROOK'S LYNSEY- REPRESENTING
THE COUNTY OF VENTURA. THANK
YOU SOME A MEMBER BENNETT-
OPERATOR KEY TO OPEN THE LINE
FOR. MS BROOKS. TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KELLY PARKLAND THE
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY AND SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE FOUR ONE INTERCOUNTY RICH
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY OR RUNS A
FARMWORKER RESOURCE PROGRAM AND
THREE LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
TO BUILD TRUST AND
RELATIONSHIPS AMONG THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AND TO
ASSIST IN FACILITATING PROMPT
RESOLUTION WORKPLACE CONCERN
SUCH A PAY REAL ISSUE THE
WORKING CONDITIONS. NAVIGATING
AVAILABLE PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
LEVERAGING EXISTING RESOURCES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED THE
CAN HAVE SERVED OVER A THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS FARMWORKERS HAVE
CONNECTED WITH THE COUNTY ON
VARIOUS ISSUES INCLUDING
EMPLOYMENT LABOR LAWS HOUSING
IMMIGRATION FINANCIAL AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND MANY OTHER
ENQUIRIES RELATED TO SUPPORT
SERVICES IN ADDITION THE
PROGRAM RECEIVED AND PROCESSED
OVER THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR THE
FARMER HOUSEHOLD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. INTERCOUNTY EXPERIENCE
IN DEVELOPING OPERATING A FARM
WORKER RESOURCE PROGRAM POINTS
TO POSITIVE OUTCOMES INCREASED
ASSISTANCE IN CONNECTION WITH
THE SERVICES THAT KEEP PEOPLE
HOUSED FED AND FINANCIALLY
STABLE AB NINE FORTY ONE OFFERS
NECESSARY SUPPORTS TO EXPAND
AND REPLICATE THE MODEL
FARMWORKER RESOURCE CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
PANDEMIC HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE
ESSENTIAL MAKE NATURE OF
AGRICULTURAL WORK AND
PRIORITIZING SUPPORT TO THIS
COMMUNITY OF WORKERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE TURRET COUNTY
EXPERIENCES COUNTY URGES YOUR
SUPPORT. AT EIGHTY NINE FOUR
ONE. THANK YOU MS BROOKS LENZI
ARE. DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT AMONG. WE SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE FOUR ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINE FOUR ONE AND WE'RE GOING
TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
FORTY PLEASE ON MUTE. THANK YOU
FORTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT. CALOMEL MCMILLAN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FAMILY
WINEMAKERS A CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF AB NINE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU TO AVOID PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOUNG ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY
TWO. YOU ARE OPEN. ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE ON MUTE. NINE ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE ON MUTE.
OTHER. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. NOW
ONE NINETY TWO IS NOT
RESPONDING WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
QUEUING UP. ONE MOMENT THEY
SHOULD BE WITH US AND ONE ONE
MOMENT MATTER CHAIR. THANK YOU.
KILL.
AND TWO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SURELY HERRIMAN I REPRESENT
BEST START LANCASTER AND I LIVE
IN. LANCASTER'S CALIFORNIA AND
I WOULD STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE PLEASE. AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR I DON'T SEE ANY-
PUBLIC SUPPORT IN THE ROOM DO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SUPPORT IN THE- VIDEO PLEASE
REMOTE NOW OKAY- OKAY DO. DO WE
HAVE ANY ONE IN OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE OPERATOR. SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR BILL AB NINE
FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR EIGHTY
FEET. NINE FORTY ONE. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU OPERATOR. I SEE DO
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE FEED
OF YOUR NO OKAY- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
MISTER GIBSON. THE AUTHOR WOULD
WOULD BE INCLINED I WOULD LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THE BILL I THINK WE TALKED A
BIRD IS LEGAL RESOURCES. AND I
THINK THAT AT THIS TIME WITH
THIS PANDEMIC PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES SO THAT
THEY CAN BETTER THEMSELVES AND
BETTER THEIR SITUATION I THINK
THIS. I'M SPEAKS TO AGAIN A
BOMB A POPULATION THAT SHOULD
HAVE RESOURCES MADE AVAILABLE
TO THEM SO I WOULD BE HONORED
IF YOU WOULD. PLEASE ADD ME AS
A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL THANK
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
NINETEEN WILL. CERTAINLY DO
THAT. THE STRUGGLE. YEAH A. I.
A. WOULD ECHO- MEMBER- YOU KNOW
OUR OFFICE IS BEEN DOING THIS
TOO YOU KNOW I WHEN WE FIRST AS
A FRESHMAN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HOW DO WE HELP THOSE
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW THAT DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT INSTEAD
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS UP. YOU KNOW THIS
IS SUCH AN NEEDED. NOT JUST IN
YOUR COMMUNITY BUT THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE STATE SO- IF I CAN BE
ADDED AS CO AUTHOR. YOU KNOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE HAPPY THAT.
AFTER TWENTY K. THANK YOU ALSO
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO
HERE IS- SO- TO ASK A ELIGIBLE
FOR CALIFORNIA SO TO ESTABLISH
AND FUND THE FARM RECORD
RESOURCES- CAN YOU DEFINE WHAT
YOU MEAN BY- ELIGIBLE ALL
COUNTIES. AND SECOND QUESTION
IS- IT IF THIS OF FUN DATE
THOUGH ANY- EXPENSES INCURRED A
BY THE COUNTY IS UP FOR RE
ESTABLISHING AND IMPLEMENTING
THIS PROGRAM- A WITH AB OLD RE
IMPOSED A STATE THE- I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO MANY MEMBERS
THE- THE- PROGRAM ONLY TALK
ABOUT ELIGIBLE PROGRAMS A
WORKGROUP THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH A WORKGROUP. NETWORK
GROUP WILL ESTABLISH- CRITERIA
FOR GRANT PROGRAM- WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH IS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE FOR
COUNTIES THAT ARE WILLING TO DO
THAT SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
WITH SOME COUNTIES IN ADVANCE.
AND IF WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE
PROACTIVE AND WANT TO DO IT
THEN WE KNOW WOULD HAVE QUICK
IMPLEMENTATION MAKE ACTUALLY
HAD THOSE COUNTIES BUT THERE
WILL BE A WORK GROUP THAT WILL
DETERMINE THE CRITERIA. NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO. THE BY THE
WAY THIS IS STRUCTURED IS
COUNTIES ARE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DESIGN IT IS TO HAVE
COUNTIES GET FIFTY PERCENT-
MATCH FROM- THE STATE UP TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR FOR THE PROGRAM. SO
COUNTIES WOULD PUT UP TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
STATE WOULD PUT UP TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FUND- THE
MOST IT'S MOSTLY THE EMPLOYEES
THAT WOULD BE WORKING. IN THE
PHARMACY SOURCE PROGRAM. ACTOR
AND THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM
THIS ISN'T- YOU KNOW A PER
PERMANENT ONGOING FUNDING- THIS
IS USING ONE TIME FUNDING-
POTENTIALLY THREE YEARS OF THAT
SO THAT THEY CAN GET
ESTABLISHED. AND SEE WHETHER
IT'S WORKING WHETHER TO PROGRAM
THEY WANT TO KEEP WORKING ON.
POTENTIALLY WE WOULD THEN IF
THEY'RE HAPPY WITH THAT- WE
EXPAND THIS- IF THEY'RE HAPPY
WITH IT WE CAN EXPAND THE
FUNDING TO OTHER COUNTIES AND-
WE WHAT WE HAVE TO DECIDE DOWN
THE ROAD YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID
WAS SELL ONGOING FUNDING BUT
THIS WOULD BE. ONE TIME FUNDING
NOT PERMANENT ONGOING FIVE DO
YOU HAVE A ROUGH IDEA HOW MANY
COUNTY SO MAY BE ELIGIBLE WE'RE
WE'RE- HI I DON'T HAVE A ROUGH
IDEA HOW MANY BE ELIGIBLE
BECAUSE THE CRITERIA HAVING ALL
BEEN ESTABLISHED YET BY THE
WORKING GROUP- BUT THE IDEA
HERE IS FOR THIS PILOT TO BE
FOR COUNTIES. SO IF YOU GET TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWO. TWO
YEARS THAT WOULD- TAKE CARE FOR
COUNTIES AND SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. OKAY. THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE TO SOMEONE
I WOULD NEVER ONE APPRECIATE
QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE A CO
AUTHOR IS BEING WILLING TO SIGN
ON- AND- I APPRECIATE JUSTICE
STAFF WORK IN TERMS OF-
COORDINATING WITH US IN ADVANCE
OF US ACTUALLY SUBMITTING THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL I DO WANT
EVERYBODY NO WE ARE CURRENTLY
STILL WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE OF-
DISCUSSED WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WE FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THE WAY THINGS GO FURTHER THE
SPIRIT OF WHERE WE ARE WITH
THIS AND THOSE WILL BE- ADDED-
THE NEXT TIME THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. ALONG WITH THE CO
AUTHORS NAMES ARE HERE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
COMMITTEE CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I'D CHOI CHOI I GIPSON
GIPSON ICE DOWN STONE HI PUT UP
THE LITTLE GUY LORD LORD HI THE
VOTED EIGHT TO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME OF. PROBABLY A LOT OF.
OKAY AS SOMEONE IN GARCIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON AB.
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO MY
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I PRESENT
TO YOU AB. EIGHT SIX EIGHT ZERO
EXPENSES- PROGRAM THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH EMERGENCY FUNERAL
EXPENSE FUND TO REIMBURSE YOUR
COSTS WHEN THE CAUSE OF DEATH.
IS DIRECTLY TO A DECLARED STATE
EMERGENCY. THANK YOU I WILL-
KEEP IT SHORT THE FOCUS IS TO
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM AND- FOCUS
ON COVER NINETEEN- THE DEATHS
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE THE TO DATE.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HELP- OUR LOW AND
VERY LOW INCOME FAMILIES. TAKE
CARE THAT COSTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SOME WOMEN
AND SO- IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WITH HERE TODAY
CORRECT OKAY- OPERATOR CAN WE-
OPEN THE LINE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT ON AB EIGHT SIX EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY%
ZERO. ONE CHILD BY ZERO FOR AB
EIGHT SIX EIGHT. YEAH DO YOU
HAVE ANY. YES. YEAH KEVIN OF
THE COLDEST CALIFORNIA WILL
PROVIDES ORGANIZATIONS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD AND FOR
ANYBODY ELSE I WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT SIX
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
FORTY SIX. TWO FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY ARE NOT
RESPONDING OKAY AND ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR- I
DON'T SEE ANY SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM OR IN THE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY IN THE V. W. R. RANCHO- IS.
DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IT ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR.
CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB. EIGHT
SIX EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT SIX EIGHT. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM AND
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION IN THE VW
OUR ROOM- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR MISTER
GIBSON- I THINK THIS IS A- WELL
THOUGHT OUT A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION POLICY- I THINK
THAT AGAIN- WE TALK ABOUT FIFTY
FIVE. THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND IT'S ONLY THE TIME
WHEN THERE'S A PANDEMIC- THEY
WANT TO PROVIDE SOME HELP TO
THOSE TO BURY- INDIVIDUALS- I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING IT'S MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE TAKING
CARE OF- I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE- IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
WHO JUST DIDN'T HAVE MONEY. WHO
THIS PANDEMIC- HAS TAKEN THEM
OUT AND THEIR FAMILIES WISH
THEY COULD- BURY THEM BUT THEY
HAD TO DO RESERVE RIVER REVERT
TO- BEING CREMATED- AND SO I
THINK THAT IF IN FACT THE
FAMILY WANTS TO LAY SOMEONE TO
REST DURING A PANDEMIC WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE AND I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- HOPE THE AUTHOR
WOULD. INCLUDE ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. YES TENNIS
DAVIS I THINK INTERESTED- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING BILL I JUST
HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS- ONE CAN
APPLY FOR THE EXPENSE
ASSISTANCE IS FAMILY FRIENDS.
AND THE SECOND ONE IS- THIS IS
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES OR CAN
ANYONE APPLY FOR THIS
ASSISTANCE SORT OF SO THE
PROGRAM WILL BE FOCUSED ON LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WERE LOOKING AT
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA IS
UTILIZING. THRESHOLDS LIKE- THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM THAT- REALLY
TAKES A GOOD- ENCOMPASSING- I
GUESS BURKE- SECTOR OF THE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
TEARS WERE LOOKING AT. A
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES WILL
WORK WITH US TO ESTABLISH THAT-
SO THAT'S WHO IS ELIGIBLE IN
TERMS OF WHO CAN ASK FOR THE
REIMBURSEMENT. IT IS ANYONE WHO
HAS THE ACTUAL. INVOICE RIGHT
THE TICKET THAT SAYS YOU KNOW
WE PAID FOR- AT THE FUNERAL
COST- FOR AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
LOST HER LIFE. IN THIS CASE TO
CALL IT AND- THEY CAN BE
REIMBURSED UP TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND OR THE DIFFERENCE
THAT MAY BE REMAINING- THAT
SHOULD BE PAID DIRECTLY TO A
FUNERAL HOME HOW TO COVER THE
EXPENSES- WE'RE HOPING TO
UTILIZE. SIMILAR FRAMEWORKS
THAT HAVE BEEN USED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SERVICES WHERE LOCAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS HELP
FACILITATE. THE PROCESS MAKING
IT EASIER- OBTAIN. AND THEY'RE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY- FEEL COMFORTABLE
CONFIDENT- WORKING WITH- SO
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION IT DOESN'T I JUST I
JUST WANT TO. MAKE A COMMENT I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE OBVIOUSLY
THAT THIS IS- THIS IS
DEFINITELY GONNA BE BENEFICIAL.
BUT SADLY THERE'S ALWAYS FRAUD
AND WE LOOK AT EIGHTY D. AND
HOW MUCH MONEY WE LOST THERE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
REALLY PUT IN SOME SAFETY-
GUIDELINES HERE THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE REALLY CHECKING JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS LEGIT.
AND YOU KNOW AND IN THIS
NOTHING GOING ON BETWEEN YOU
KNOW ONE PARTY TO ANOTHER PARTY
THAT'S THAT'S ALL I ASK.
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW GOT
DOCUMENTS THAT WILL BE.
REQUIRED IN ALL CERTIFICATES OF
DEATH YOU KNOW FROM THE LOCAL
COUNTY AGAIN IN A PAPERWORK
FROM A. FUNERAL HOME OR THE
EXPENSES WERE MADE. AND OTHER.
LESS OF YOU KNOW KIND OF
BACKSTOP THAT WE'RE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE- PROVIDE THAT
CERTAINTY THAT THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. ARE RECEIVING THE MONEY
AND WE KNOW THAT- THE BILL.
WILL ALSO ESTABLISHED A PROGRAM
FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES
CALIFORNIA IS FACED WITH A
HANDFUL OF OTHER. CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE WE NEED TO DECLARE
EMERGENCIES WHETHER IT BE AN
EARTHQUAKE. AND NOT JUST
PROPERTY BUT LIFE IS LOST AS
WELL AS SOME FIRES WHERE WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS-
UNFORTUNATELY ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THAT AS WELL SO.
THE QUESTION THANK YOU. DR CHOI
DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS YEAH. I
THINK THIS QUESTION SO TOUCHED
UPON BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THE- THE ELIGIBILITY IS- DID
YOU SAVE HALF OF FOR THOSE OF
THOSE WHO RECEIVING CALFRESH-
OR ANYBODY CAN APPLY FOR THIS.
THIS THIS ONE QUESTION FOR ALL
CERTIFIED WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
CALFRESH CRITERIA. AS THE
ELIGIBILITY. TO ENCOMPASS THE
LOW OR VERY LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF CALIFORNIA IN THIS CASE WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. BY COPA
NINETY YEAH IF THAT'S THE CASE
AS I UNDERSTAND EACH KALLONI-
IT HAS- WELL MOSTLY PROGRAMS A
FOUR ENGINE PEOPLE FOR FINLAND
EXPENSES. AND THE MOST OF THE
EXPENSES WILL BE TAKEN CARE OF.
THUS OF MY UNDERSTANDING IF
THAT'S THE CASE IT ISN'T IS SO
REDUNDANT UNNECESSARY. NO
DOCTOR THERE IS NO KNOWN
PROGRAM THAT ENCOMPASSES THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD PROVIDE A FUNERAL
ASSISTANCE EXPENSES ARE
REIMBURSEMENTS- THAT WE KNOW OF
NOW THERE ARE PLACES THAT HAVE
DECIDED TO USE THEIR FEDERAL
FUNDING- THROUGH CARES ACT TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE OTHERS HAVE USED IT
FOR OTHER- ESSENTIAL NEEDS OF
THE POPULATION THAT THEY SERVE-
I KNOW OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
USING THEIR DOLLARS- TO PROVIDE
FUNERAL ASSISTANCE I KNOW
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE PROVIDED
HERE WILL PAY. AS TO UTILIZE
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS SO YOU MAY
BE REFERRING TO CERTAIN PLACES
IN THE STATE WHERE THEY MAY BE
DOING THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM BUT
THERE IS NO STATEWIDE PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE PERMANENTLY
ESTABLISHED IN THE SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS DECLARED
EMERGENCY OUR FUTURE DECLARED
EMERGENCIES AND THAT'S THE
INTENT. OF THE BILL. AND I GET
THE IMPRESSION THIS IS
RETROACTIVE FOR ANYONE WHO- IT
HAD TO. FAMILIES THAT FLED DUE
TO A CORVETTE NINETEEN- SO
OBVIOUSLY DISORDER- CALL VOTE
TO PASS THE- CARISSA AND THE
LAWS OF MOVING FOR. IS THE
TRUTH MARCH FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY IS WHEN THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND SO THAT'S THE BEGINNING UP
UNTIL THE POINT WHERE HE SAYS
WE ARE NO LONGER IN THIS
EMERGENCY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
PASSED THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
WILL BE ABLE TO APPLY AND IF
ELIGIBLE RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THE COST. CHAU WILL ORDER
WITH HIS CONTINUING WEST ALONG
AS AS SOMEBODY DEFINING SAID
THAT THAT WAS A CONNECTED TO
CALL THE NINETEEN THEN THE OLD
PALATABLE NOT BASED UPON THEIR
INCOME SO D. THEY WILL BE
ELIGIBLE BASED ON INCOME RIGHT
AND WE'RE SAYING LOW INCOME AND
I'LL AGAIN REITERATE THE
CALFRESH CRITERIA IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HIGHS DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE CAUGHT TIED TO COFFEE
NINETEEN DEATHS SO SPECIFICALLY
THIS EMERGENCY IS COVER
NINETEEN- POST CODE NINETEEN IT
MAY BE AN EARTHQUAKE. THAT
CAUSES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
LOSS OF LIFE IN YOUR AREA OF MY
AREA THAT IS PRONE TO
EARTHQUAKES- AND THEN THE
GOVERNOR WOULD DECLARE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HE WOULD THEN NEED TO
FUND THE PROGRAM AND THEN
PEOPLE WILL BECOME ELIGIBLE
FOR. THIS PROGRAM BUT WHEN THIS
EMERGENCY ENDS THE PROGRAM ENDS
AND IF SO ANYTHING GOVERNOR
DECLARES SO DECLARATION OF.
EMERGENCY WATER ENTITLED. YEAH
SIR SO THE MINUTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE
EMERGENCY. AND WE GAVE EXAMPLES
EARTHQUAKES- FIRES ANOTHER
PANDEMIC GOD FOR BID WE DON'T
HAVE TO SEE THAT AGAIN BUT-
THEN THE PROGRAM WILL NEED TO
BE FUNDED. AND THEN PEOPLE CAN
BEGIN TO APPLY. HAVE YOU HAD
ANY IDEA OF- FROM THE PAST-
RECORD TELEPHONE SUCH.
EMERGENCY RELATED TASKS IN THE
FUTURE WHAT THE COSTS WILL ALL
FALL INTO SPEEDY TO COST WOULD
BE. NO SIR WE HAVEN'T. THANK
YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE TO
SOME OF HER LOOK I ATE GOOD
QUESTIONS FROM FROM ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND A BIT ON
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS
AND DOES AND I THINK IT
DEMONSTRATES A HIGH LEVEL OF
COMPASSION BY LEADERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA ACKNOWLEDGING THE
IMPACT THAT COVER NINETEEN IS
HAD ON ON POOR PEOPLE AND- IT
SADDENS ME TO SEE THAT
FAMILIES. HAVE TO STILL YOU
KNOW SUFFERED NOT ONLY THE JOB
LOSS AND ALL OF THE OTHER
BURDENS THAT ARE COME FROM IT
AND NOW IT'S A DEATH WHERE THEY
CAN'T RESPECTFULLY LAY THEIR
LOVED ONE TO REST- YOU KNOW YOU
SEE CANS AT THE GOT THE STORY
C. CAR WASHES HAPPENING HERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO DO. THE RIGHT THING AND BE
ABLE TO HELP OUR LOW VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BURY THEIR
LOVED ONES THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER. TO
HAVE A MOTION. WHICH THE SECOND.
YEAH THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES DAVIES
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D CHOI
THE FOURTEENTH CHINA VOTING
GIPSON. GIPSON ICE DOWN STONE
ARAMBULA WHO DON'T. LORD LORD I.
SIX THE VOTER SIXTIES ERA THANK
YOU. OKAY AND SOME WOMEN
GRAYSON ARE YOU READY 2% ON AB.
FOUR SEVEN NINE. OKAY. MISTER
GRIFFIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I DO
WANT TO- ACKNOWLEDGE AND
RECOGNIZE THE SPECIAL WORK- THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE
BEEN SO KIND OF- AND INVITE
SOME GUIDANCE TO THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED AND IF THIS BILL WAS
TO MOVE FORWARD I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT. I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
FOUR SEVENTY NINE WHICH AUTHORS
A PERSON TO APPLY TO BE A
FAMILY CHILD CARE SECONDARY
LICENSEE FOR A PRIMARY LICENSEE
AND REQUIRES THAT A SECONDARY
LICENSEE TO MEET ALL LICENSE
ARE REQUIREMENTS APPLICABLES TO
A LICENSEE EXCEPT THE
REQUIREMENT TO RESIDE IN THE
HOME IN WHICH THE FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME IS OPERATED. FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES ARE A CRITICAL
AND VITAL SERVICE FOR FAMILIES
AND LIKE CHILD CARE CENTERS
THAT OPERATE IN COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES ARE OPERATED IN
INDIVIDUALS RESIDENTIAL HOME
MAKING THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
THE COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
LOCATION MOST WORKING PARENTS
SELECTOR CHILD CARE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE OF LOCATION AND COST
FOR INSTANCE SINGLE WORKING
MOTHERS WHO DO NOT HAVE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TRANSPORTATION GOING
TO WORK AND ALSO FINDING WAYS
TO TRANSPORT THEIR CHILD TO A
CHILD CARE FACILITY AND BACK
CAN PROVE TO BE A HUGE
CHALLENGE AND BARRIER TO
ACCESS. HOWEVER IF THERE IS A
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
AVAILABLE AND OPEN DIRECTLY
WITHIN HER NEIGHBORHOOD SHE IS
ABLE TO ACCESS QUALITY CARE AND
STILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WHILE THE STATE HAS
INCREASED INVESTMENTS INTO THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSED FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
HAS BEEN A STEADY DECLINE HAS
BEEN A STEADY DECLINE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND THIS DECLINE
HAS ONLY BEEN EXASPERATED
EXASPERATED BY THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY TROUBLING BECAUSE
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO OFFER FLEXIBLE
HOURS OF CARE AND ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN CENTER BASED
CARE ASSISTING WORKING FAMILIES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. SINCE MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY FINANCIAL LOSSES
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS
HAVE FORCED MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES TO CLOSE PERMANENTLY.
FURTHER INCREASING THE GAP IN
THE NEED FOR CHILD CARE AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF CHILD CARE
SLOTS AB FOUR SEVENTY NINE
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE DECLINING
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME SUPPLY.
AND THE RAPIDLY INCREASING GAP
OF AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE SLOTS. BY CREATING A
SECONDARY LICENSEE THIS WILL
ALLOW QUALIFIED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO BE PAIRED WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY OPERATING
SPACE. THIS WILL CREATE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE CHOOSING TO- WORK AS A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER WHO MEET
LICENSE ARE REQUIREMENTS BUT DO
NOT HAVE THE RESIDENTIAL SPACE.
TO OPERATE A CHILD CARE HOME
ULTIMATELY AB FOUR SEVENTY NINE
WILL IMPROVE ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE QUALITY OR QUALITY CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION BY
FILLING THE GAP IN CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WITHIN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. BY INCREASING THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME SUPPLY
WITHIN UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND AIMS TO
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MY
STAFF AND I HAVE SPOKEN WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND VARIOUS
CHILD CARE PROVIDER
STAKEHOLDERS AND ARE AWARE
THERE ARE CONCERNS. WITH THE
BILL AND CURRENT LANGUAGE I
HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE BILL AS
IT MOVES FORWARD THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ENSURE
THAT WE INCLUDE AMENDMENTS THAT
ALL IMPACTED PARTIES CAN AGREE
UPON WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY WITNESS. JIM
MILLER. OFTEN LEAVE EXECUTIVE.
DIRECTOR OF WATCH ME GROW EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
OPERATOR. YOU OPEN THE LINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND THANK YOU GRAYSON
BOTHERS YOU'RE DOING- UNTIL
THAT AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS JIMMY
LONNIE AND I AM THE OWNER OF
WATCHING PROGRAMS CHILD CARE OF
THE LAYOUT HAVE BEEN OPERATING
FOR NINE YEARS AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SOLANO COUNTY
PROVIDERS AS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SEVEN NOT-
EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN NINE OF THE
BILL WILL CHANGE THE WORLD OF
CHILDCARE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
BEST. OF NOT JUST THE PROVIDERS
WILL ALSO PUT CHILDREN THE
FAMILIES AND OUR ECONOMY ACT AT
THE CHILD CARE IS VITAL TO OUR
CATS TO OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
SUBFAMILIES CHAPTER HELD THE
OFTEN FORGOTTEN ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINE WE WERE ATTENTION WORKERS
TREE CALLED THE WHICH ARE
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
THE OTHER THIRTEEN YEAR OLD AND
PROVIDE TOP. HERE WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT- THERE HAD BEEN
CLOSED WITH THE FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME DUE TO THE FACT
IT MAKES A HIGH PERCENTAGE WERE
MOSTLY SENIOR PROVIDERS WILL
CLOSE DUE TO THEIR HIGHER RISK
OF TRANSMISSION OF CALL THE
NINETEEN ARE YOU ALSO HAVE
THOSE PROVIDERS WHO ARE JUST
AFRAID OF COLD IN NINETEEN AND
DIDN'T WANT TO BE IN CONTACT
WITH ANYONE ALL OF THAT
PROVIDER FOR A MONTH UNTIL I
STARTED THINKING ABOUT. HOW
MUCH CLOSER WAS AFFECTING THE
CHILDREN WHO WERE NO LONGER IN
MY CHAIR THEY WEREN'T YOU KNOW
WHAT THEIR NEEDS WHAT THEY
NEEDED AND I START THINKING
ABOUT THE FAMILY ALSO WHO ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME LOOKING FOR
CHILD CARE BECAUSE MOST CHILD.
HERE CAN'T CLOSE. SO WHAT COULD
HAPPEN DIDN'T CLOSE ABOUT CHILD
HOME. YOU HAVE BEEN HAVING A
THEY CAN'T LIE TO- THE PROVIDER
TO. WITH HAD AND I TO HIGH
SOMEONE OPERATE AT THE PROVIDER
IN THE BUSINESS CONNECTED. OUR
INTO. CARE FOR TO. WHICH ALSO
ALLOWS THE PARENTS CONTINUE IN
THE WORK. AND NOT HAVE TO MOVE
JOB IS TO LACK OF CHILD CARE WE
IS JUST ANOTHER AND IS. THAT
I'M NOT A BAD IMAGE. IT'S AT
THAT CLOSE THE FAMILY HOME.
CARE SPACES. BY 23% MY NAME.
THAT LOOK LIKE A- OF. A THAT.
CHILL THAT WERE WITHOUT. HERE
AND I KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE WAY
THAT. IT IS THE AT THE- THAT.
TWO POINT THREE MILLION. IN
UNDERSERVED. DISADVANTAGED HALL
BY NEED A CHILD HERE AND DO NOT
RECEIVE SERVICES. AND THAT 86%
OF THOSE CHILDREN ARE CHILDREN
OF COLOR. SB FOUR SEVEN NINE-
WORKED ON THE CHAPTER
HEALTHCARE UPGRADE PROVIDE CARE
FOR THAT CHECK. ALTHOUGH THERE
IS A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
FAMILIES NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
CHILD CARE DUE TO LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION. AB FOUR SEVEN
NOW WE CAN PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY
FOR MANY FAMILIES TO HAVE A
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE OF THEIR HOME.
AB FOUR SEVEN. FOUR SEVEN I
WILL CREATE MORE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THOSE
SEEKING A CAREER IN THE BILL
UP. EARLY CARE AND LEARNING.
THIS WILL ALSO BE A WAY TO GET
PARENTS INVOLVED CREATE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM. MANY OF
PROVIDERS. WOULD YOU- THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW POTENTIAL
CHILD CARE BUSINESS ALL OF OUR
SPORTS STAFF. AND BATTLE SHOWS
UP AT 10% OF CHILD HERE IN THE
U. S. R. CONSIDER QUALITY ONLY
TEN PERCENT. I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE JUST IN IT
FOR THE MONEY AND THEY HAVE A
DEAL REQUIRED TO TAKE EARLY
CARE AND LEARNING. COURT FELT
SB FOUR SEVEN NINE THE PROVIDER
CAN HIRE SOMEONE. WHO HAS A
PASSION TO CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN. AND HAVE THEM SERVE
AS THE LEAD TEACHER. BEEN OLDER
CAMPERS DO WHATEVER THEY REALLY
HAVE A PASSION FOR AND IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW WHATEVER YOU'RE ABOUT
THE MONEY. THIS BILL CAN. ALSO
ENCOURAGE MORE PROVIDERS INTO
TO CONTINUE THE AND AGREE EARLY.
EDUCATION WITH WILL INCREASE
THE- OF CARE THAT. TO THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. SO SB
FOUR SEVEN NINE THE NEED. IN IS
THE NEEDS ARE IMPROVE ACCESS
AND UPDATE. THE CHILD CARE AND
THE- WHICH- BECAUSE- AT THE
BACK RIGHT. BY PENDANT.
CHILDCARE CLUB. WHO HAVE A LOT
WITH THE- WILL NOW HOW AFTER TO
RE- OPEN WITH THE- ONE. THE
NEEDS ALL THE REQUIRED. WE WILL
HAVE NEW. AS A FAMILY TO CARE
HOME SECURITY WILL ALSO BE ABLE
TO GO. CHIU CARE FOR THOSE TWO
WITHOUT ACCESS WHICH CARE TO
THE- OF TO WEEKS. HAPPENS BEARD
IN OUR- TO THE WORK. WELL WHAT
BEEN CREATED MORE. DROUGHT AB.
FOR BOTH THE A CAREER IN SHOW.
AT THE CARE FOR. WE WILL ALSO.
TO THEM. THE ECONOMY WE HAVE TO
NEVER FORGET THAT THERE ARE NO.
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WITHOUT CHILD
HERE. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS. I. ON EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES NOVEMBER
OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR CAN YOU
THE LINE FOR SO. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR
AB FOUR SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SHOW
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR AB FOUR
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT.
YEAH SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR OPEN
PLEASE TURN YOUR PHONE DOWN.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB I'M SORRY
I PRESSED FOR SUPPORT BUT I'M
IN OPPOSITION OKAY IT WORKS Q.
OUT NEXT TIME AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KARINA
LIKE A WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER YES HERE IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL ONE
OF WHICH IS THAT THE BILL COULD
JEOPARDIZE ITS SPECIAL HOUSING
PROTECTION FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND CREATE MORE
BARRIERS FOR THEM. OPEN WE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
AUTHOR AND HE'S COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM. ON THAT WE
ARE NOT TAKING A POSITION ON
THE BELL TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OPERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ELSE QUEUED UP FOR
SUPPORT THIS IS FOR SUPPORT.
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR
ARE OPEN. ONE I DID IT AGAIN.
OKAY THE SUPPORT ONLY LATER
GERMAN RIGHT NOW FOR ONCE FOR
AB SET FOR SEVENTY NINE OKAY
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONLY ONE
WITH THIS MARKET IS DOUBLING TO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE ACTED BY
REPRESENTS EIGHT EIGHT B. AND
THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS OF
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ I LIVE INTO
MACULA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. OKAY THANK YOU THIS
IS FOR. SUPPORT FOR AB FOUR
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT. WE WILL GO TO WHY 263% ON
EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO SIXTY THREE.
AND THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF
QUEUE OKAY- I DON'T SEE ANY
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY IN THE V. W. R.
ROOM TODAY. I DO WE HAVE ANY
ONE ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR. TO SHOW OPPOSITION
NOW TO EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOUR SEVEN
NINE THE MOMENT WE HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP AND WE WILL
GO BACK TO ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE SEVENTY.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT WITH ME- MYNAME IS
NANCY WHY IT AND I'M THE PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILY CHILD CARE NETWORK. AND
WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY NINE. WE BELIEVE
THAT IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT ALL
FAMILY TALK YOUR LICENSEES
CONTINUE TO BE PERSONS. WHO
RESIDE IN THE HOME AND ARE THE
PRIMARY CARE GIVER. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE TRANSFER OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE FOR THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME- WOULD
TAKE THE FAMILY AND THE HOME
OUT OF FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME.
AND WITH IT THE HEART AND SOULOUT OF FAMILY CHILD CARE
THROUGHOUT THE AGES WE'VE
UNDERSTOOD THAT HOME IS WHERE
THE HEART IS AND THEY BE KNOWN
THAT OUR FAMILIES THAT GIVE US
CARE SECURITY INTERPRET THAT
YOU CATION. ASSEMBLY OUT THERE
LIKE ME SEAT OPEN THEIR HEARTS
AND THEIR OWN HOME AND SHARE
THEIR OWN FAMILIES WITH THE
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE AND
THEY'RE LIKE NO OTHER CARE
GIVERS IN THIS WAY. WE MUST.
APPRECIATE AND PROTECT THE
SPECIAL FEATURES AND BENEFITS
THAT FAMILY CHILD CARE HAS TO
OFFER. PLEASE DO WHAT YOU CAN
TO SHOW YOUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE FAMILY CHILD CARE HEROES
THAT STAY OPEN. OR REOPEN
QUICKLY RISKING THEIR LIVES TO
KEEP ALL THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
GOING WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY OF
THE Q. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PART ONE PRINTER TO HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ALIVE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN.
YES ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S KAREN
KOEHLER AND I'M FROM CREATIVE
JOURNEYS- FAMILY HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR THE FACT THAT IT DOES
NOTHING TO PROTECT. THE CURRENT
PUBLIC CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IT
OPENS THAT UP TO A LOT OF
LIABILITY. AND IT DOESN'T STOP
ANYBODY FROM HOLDING MORE THAN-
ONE NIGHT. OR ONE SECONDARY
LICENSE IT DOESN'T PROTECT THE
CHILDREN IN OUR CARE IT DOESN'T
PROTECT THE FAMILIES IN OUR
CARE AND I AFTER DUE TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR TO EVERYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
THREE THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM- DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. SOMEONE IN CHOI.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON I THINK
I REALLY UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
OF THE APPEAL TO MAKE A MORE
CHILD CARE FACILITIES AVAILABLE
BECAUSE OF ALWAYS- FROM MY
EXPERIENCE A SHORTAGE OF POOR
CHILD CARE CENTERS. EVEN THOUGH
INTENT IS GOOD BUT THE- I READ
THAT THE ANALYSIS A VERY
CAREFULLY AND- I HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS- SINCE AT THIS BILL
IS TO ALLOW FAMILY TAKE CARE.
OF FACILITY WITHOUT HAVING TO
LEAVE IN THAT HOME. SO THAT IS
SO IF I WAS CO HOMEOWNER-
OPERATING AND THAT MEANS I CAN-
RAN TEN AS THE HOUSE. TICKETS
ARE ON OUR OWN LEVY IN THAT
pTHIRD ONE FOURTH ONE. IS THAT
THE ALLOWABLE RESELLERS YOU ARE
REFERRING AS A SECONDARY I
SINCE NO SIR. SO THE WAY IT
WOULD WORK IS- AND THIS WOULD
ALSO ANSWER ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS IS THERE IS
NO TRANSFER OF LICENSE. THE
PRIMARY LICENSEE HAS TO BE THE
HOMEOWNER THAT LIVES IN THE
HOME SO WHAT WE DON'T WANT AND
THIS IS WHERE WE EED TO.
TIGHTEN UP LANGUAGE AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH LEAD COUNSEL IN
WITH- WITH OPPOSITION WHO
STATED THEY WERE WORKING WITH
US AS WELL AS THIS COMMITTEE-
BUT WHAT WE DON'T WANT AS
CORPORATIONS COMING IN IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND JUST OPENING
UP A BUNCH OF DAYCARES UNDER A
CORPORATE NAME SO YOU HAVE TO
BE A PRIME A PRIMARY LICENSEE
HAS TO BE THE RESIDENT OF THE
HOME. OR OWNER OF THE HOME AND
A RESIDENT OF THE HOME THE
DIFFERENCE IS RIGHT NOW IT
REQUIRES IF- IF YOU'RE A PRIME
IF YOU'RE THE LICENSEE IT
REQUIRES YOU TO BE THERE 80% OF
THE TIME AND ACCORDING TO
RULES- THAT BAKER CAN ONLY BE
CLOSED LEGITIMATELY FOR TWO
WEEKS OUT OF THE YEAR. SO WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT DOES ALLOW A
HOMEOWNER WHO POSSIBLY HAS A
JOB. BUT THEY HAVE OPEN SPACE.
THE HOME AND THEY POSSIBLY KNOW
SOMEONE THAT'S IN THE CHILD
CARE FIELD WANTS TO ENTER THE
CHILD CARE FOR OF. THAT LIVE
SOMEWHERE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SPACE. THAT HOMEOWNER WOULD
BE THE PRIMARY LICENSEE THEY
COULD BRING AND THAT PERSON
THAT USES THEIR HOME DURING THE
DAY IS A DAY CARE. BUT THEIR
LICENSEES A SECONDARY LICENSE
HE IS SUBJECT TO THE PRIMARY
LICENSEE ALL LIABILITY. ALL ALL
INSPECTIONS. ALL REGULATORY
POLICY EVERYTHING FALLS ON THE
PRIMARY LICENSEE WHO LIVES AT
THE HOME AND WHO OWNS THE
PROPERTY. AND THEN IF THAT'S
THE CASE OF WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE A BIT OF BETWEEN. I
COULDN'T USED THE TERM AS A MY
EMPLOYEE HIRED THAT PERSON.
RATHER THAN SECONDARY PERSON
HAVING TO SECURE THE LICENSE
AGAIN RIGHT BUT IT DOES NOT
ADDRESS ALL SPEAK TO A MANAGER
YES. MANAGER IS A REQUIRED THAT
TO LOOK AT THE END OF THE-
LICENSE. BUT TWO THINGS SO WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN IF I
CALLED THE PERSON S. ON MY
EMPLOYEE. OR LICENSE HOLDER.
THERE THERE IS NO PROVISION
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN HAVE AN
ASSISTANT BUT THAT DOES NOT
NEGATE THE FACT THAT THE
PRIMARY OR THE LICENSEE HAS TO
STILL BE THERE 80% OF THE TIME
EVEN WITH AN ASSISTANT. SO
UNDER CURRENT- POLICY THERE IS
NO PROVISION TO HAVE SOMEONE
COME IN AND RIP AND REPLACE OR
BE THERE IN THE STEAD OF MAX
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO UNDER
THIS BILL. A DAY CARE WE HAVE
SOME WONDERFUL DAY CARE
PROVIDERS OUT THERE WHO ARE
HIGHLY EDUCATED BUT THEY'VE
DONE SO VOLUNTARILY THAT IS NOT
THE CASE FOR A MAJORITY OF THE
HOME DAY CARES THAT ARE OUT
THERE. THE MAJORITY THE HOME
DAY CARES OUT THERE YOU TAKE AN
EMERGENCY CLASS CPR AND UNDER
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
THAT'S IT UNDER THIS BILL IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE SECONDARY
LICENSE HE ACTUALLY HAS TO HAVE
A MINIMUM. OF A EARLY CHILDHOOD
CREDIT- CREDITS THAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO GO WORK IN A CENTER AND
SO IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
TWELVE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION CREDITS JUST TO BE
ABLE TO START. SO WITH THAT- IT
RAISES THE QUALITY OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION THAT'S
THERE IT ALSO ALLOWS THERE TO
BE THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
HOMEOWNER DOESN'T AS THE
LICENSE HE- DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
THERE THE FULL 80% OF THE TIME.
IT WOULD ALLOW SOMEONE ELSE TO
BE ABLE TO COME IN AND CONTINUE
TO OPERATE THAT- THAT- DAY CARE
SO YOU'LL BE AND IS. JUST OF
CREATING. 20% OF ALL
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE PRIMARY
LICENSE HOLDER. BY BRINGING IN
THE SECONDARY LICENSE HOLDER.
AND THEN HE CAN FILL UP- MY
ABSENCE. NOT OVER 20% NOTE 20%%
IS CURRENT RIGHT NOW. WHERE THE
PROPOSAL I SINCE E DOES CAN BE
GONE 20% OF THE TIME. WHAT THE
SECONDARY LICENSEE WHICH DOES
NOT EXIST AT THIS POINT THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT WOULD
ALLOW. FOR THAT PERSON TO NOT
HAVE TO BE THERE 80% OF THE
TIME. WELL YEAH LET TO ONLY
BEING 20% IT WOULD ALLOW THAT
SECOND A PERSON TO BE THERE
FULL TIME AND RUN THE DAY CARE.
SO SELFISH BUT IT WILL NOT-
HAVE ANY MINIMUM AMOUNT OF THE
TIME THAT THE PRIMARY A LICENSE
HOLDER CASH SHOULD BE AT THE
START THAT IS CORRECT AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE WE
WOULD REQUIRE THE PERSONAL
TRAINING IN THE WEST AT THIS
BILL ALLOWS US TO HIRE YOUNG.
MY MANAGER. A MANAGER WITH A
LICENSE. WITH ORIGINALLY
CHILDHOOD NATION YES WITH EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CREDITS SHE
SO BUT THAT WOULD NT ALLOW ME
TO OPEN THE SECONDARY HOW
ABSOLUTELY THAT WHAT IF I IF I
OR IF I HAVE A AND OF THE
PROPERTY HOLLY THE PLAN YOU
WOULD HAVE TO LIVE IT BOTH
RESIDENTS I GUESS- I. BECAUSE
WE THE RULE WOULD BE THAT YOU
WOULD NOT ONLY BE THE PROPERTY
OWNER BUT YOU WOULD BE THE
RESIDENTS. PRESENT THERE. YOU
HAVE TO SHOW PROOF THAT YOU
ACTUALLY LIVE THERE AS A
RESIDENT HOW HOW DO YOU DEFINE
REST AND SEE HOW OF 70% 80% OF
THE SELECTING A WE WOULD LOOK
INTO. WAS WE WOULD FIND SOME
LANGUAGE THAT ALREADY EXIST ON
WHAT DETERMINES RESIDENCY AND
WE WOULD INCORPORATE THAT INTO
THE BILL. I SEE OKAY HI THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU DR TRUTH.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. NOW OKAY- I
JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT AND
SOMEONE GRAYSON- YOU AND I'VE
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS AND-
I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND OPPOSITION- YOU NOTE FOR TO
PUT THE BEST PRODUCT FORWARD
AND WORK IN THIS BILL SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THANK
YOU OUR SECOND DATE IF THERE'S
ANY ROOM FOR ALL JOINT AUTHORS
I CAN BE HAPPY TO. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WITH THANK YOU DR CHOI
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA. CHOI
HI SORRY I GIPSON GIPSON ICE
STONE STONE I AM FILOPODIA
DELIVERED I WARD WARD HI. THE
VOTER SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON BECKY CHECK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY. AS
SOMEONE LACKING WOULD YOU LIKE
2% EIGHTY THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO. PRESENT AB
THIRTY ONE. AND TO NORMAL OKAY
FROM UNIVISION LOSANGELES FOR
COVERING THIS IMPORTANT LAW
GABRIEL'S LAW FROM MY DISTRICT
OFFICE IN PALMDALE. MEMBERS
THIS LEGISLATION ADDRESSES AN
ISSUE. THAT'S VERY CLOSE TO ME.
ON MAY TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
THIRTEEN. GABRIEL FERNANDES WAS
RUSHED TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
PAUL REPORTS THAT THE C. SPREE
THE- HIS INJURIES. THE COLLUDED
TO DEPRESS GOAL. SIGER AT BURJ.
BLACK IRISH. LIGATURE MARKS
SHOULD BE TIED UP. AND BB
PELLET BULLETS RIDDLED
THROUGHOUT HIS BODY. HE DIED
TWO DAYS LATER FROM. LET ME USE
AND TORTURE. HIS DEATH LOOMS
LARGE OVER THE L. VALLEY. THE
RECOLLECTION OF HIS
QUINTESSENTIAL INNOCENCE BROKE
ALL OF OUR HEARTS. WHEN WE
MOURN TOGETHER WE HEARD
INCREASINGLY ABOUT THE MISSILE
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE. AS SEVERE
NEGLECT. UNFORTUNATELY IN THE
TIME OF MY COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
WAITING FOR CHANGE. WE ALSO
LOST THE LIVES OF TEN YEAR OLD
ANTHONY OF LOS. FROM FOUR YEAR
OLD NORCOR TRUE. I APOLOGIZE.
NO NO APOLOGY NEEDED- TODAY GAY
ROLE. WE'RE ALSO SUBJECT TO
OTHER E. LEADING UP TO THEIR
DEATH. PART OF THEIR ABUSE WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOMOPHOBIA.
WELL IT IS BEING DECONSTRUCTED.
WE MUST PROVIDE BETTER
PROTECTION. THIS IS SUPPOSED
ABBOTT SORRY NO POLICY NEED TO
THE TAKE YOUR TIME. BY
PROPOSING THE CREATION OF AN
OFFICE. THAT HAS THE ABILITY TO
RECEIVE COMPLAINTS REVIEW CASES
MAINTAINED BY CHILD PROTECTIVE
AGENCIES. THIS OFFICE WILL
PROVIDE ADVOCATES. WITH THE
RESOURCE FOR EARLY INTERVENTION.
WE KNOW THE GAME WORLD FIRST
GRADE TEACHER AND OTHERS
REPEATEDLY CALLED. REPORT ABUSE
WITHOUT ANY ACTION. THIS
OFFICER THE WE'RE PROPOSING
WOULD ALSO INVESTIGATE CHILD
DEATHS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BUCER NEGLECT. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU KNOW THE SPOKESMAN WE HAVE
OVER A HUNDRED OF THESE DEATHS
HAPPENING. EVERY YEAR HER
CALIFORNIA ALONE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE. ANYWAYS
THIS PROPOSED OFFICE WOULD
REPORT FINDINGS AND DATA TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE END OF EACH
SESSION ALONG WITH SUGGESTIONS
FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. GABRIEL'S DEATH
WAS A SHOCK TO THE SYSTEM. THE
LITTLE RED OF THE CRACKS THESE
CASES FALL THROUGH ON A REGULAR
BASIS. OUR SYSTEM NEEDS REFORM
AND WHEN IT ANALYSIS. THE WILL
OF FORMS BY CAREFUL STUDY OF
THE FRACTURES TO IMPLEMENT
SOLUTIONS. OUR STATE IN MY
COMMUNITY CANNOT WAIT ANY
LONGER. HI WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MORE THAN ENOUGH. I HAVE WITH
ME FOUR HUNDRED SIGNATURES. TO
SHOW THE DEPTH OF CONCERN THAT
EXIST AND THIS IS OVER A FAIRLY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THE
SIGNATURES WERE GATHERED. BUT
ORGANIZATION CALLED STRENGTH
BASED COMMUNITY CHANGE.
ILLUSTRATED THE EAGERNESS THAT
WE HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION. AND
I HAVE ON THE LINE GABRIEL'S
COUSIN. EMILY CARRANZA
HOPEFULLY SHE'S ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU SOMEONE- OPERATOR CAN
OPEN THE LINE FOR HIS CROWN TO
PLEASE. UNDER. HELLO. YES YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. MY NAME IS
KHAN I AM THE BECAUSE OF GLOBAL
FINANCE I AM TO NOT TO SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT HIS THAT BECAUSE WE
ALL. HOW HE DIED. LET RIGHT WE
ARE HERE. I AM COMING. TO COME
TO ASK TO PAY CABLES LAW SO
WORKERS TO BE BECOME A FOR THE-
ACTIONS OF NEW. WHICH LIFE. AND
IT. ACCESS HAS ALSO BEEN
MURDERED BY THEIR PARENTS OR
PARENTS PARTNERS. BUT SEEM AN
OUT APRIL ONE IT'S- TO DO NOT
BELONG SIX UNDER. I UNDERSTAND
WE ALL HAVE RIGHTS AND THE
RIGHTS TO BE PROTECTED. THE
CHILDREN. NATTER AND CHECK IT.
IT WILL BE ANSWERED TRANSACTION
CHILDREN AND UPDATE THEM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS CARRANZA'S.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON THE LINE.
FOUR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE AND.
ZERO ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR OUR
FIRST COMMENT. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HAVE A COMMENT FOR LIKE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI YES. GO AHEAD RIGHT
WAITING IN ACTORS I'M ACTUALLY
NURSE THAT- CARED FOR GABRIEL
FERNANDEZ WILL CAME INTO THE
HOSPITAL- ON MAY TWENTY SECOND
AND I FULLY SUPPORT AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED AND HELP
THESE CHILDREN WHEN YOU GET
THAT THIS TO INUNDATED AND IS
NOT DOING THE JOB THAT THEY
SHOULD BE DOING AND I'M HOPING
THAT NOT ONLY FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WILL NEVER HAVE TO
LIVE THROUGH THIS BUT ALSO
THAT- STOP LIKE MYSELF WILL
NEVER HAVE TO SEE. AND LATER
WHEN I THOUGHT POOR GABRIEL
WENT THROUGH MY FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I ASK THAT YOU.
GUYS PLAYED TOP THAT. THANK
OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOUR MIKE IS
UP. HI MY NAME IS ERIKA
SCHWARTZ I AM WHAT AT THE CITY
AND BASS START REGION FIVE I AM
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND I
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS OF ABUSE I ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
I AM A RESIDENT OF LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND I URGE YOU GUYS TO
DO THINGS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. SHE
YEAH DID YOU MAKE YES. GO AHEAD.
WE CAN HEAR YOU CALLER. PLEASE
GO AHEAD- NOW THE REMAKE YES.
DO YOU HEAR ME NOW OKAY MY NAME
IS MARIA MY DAUGHTER AND I'M
STRONGER SUPPORTING THE THIRTY
ONE I'M FROM AB IS BUSY AND-
DEMOCRATS- AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT WITH THIRTY ONE WE
NEED SOME DENTAL STUFF HOLD ITS
APPEAL FOR THE KIDS THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. FINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN HUDSON I REPRESENTS
COMMUNITY CHANGE AS A COMMUNITY
BASED OVERALL OUT OF FARMINGTON
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
LAST FOUR NAY I REPRESENT AS
CPC- FROM THE CITY OF CARSON
AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB THREE ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREW
SANCHEZ WITH SHRINK BASED
COMMUNITY CHANGE WILMINGTON I
STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OR MIKE IT UP.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALLY AND I PRESENT SPCC AND THE
FAMILY OF THE VICTIM CAN OPEN
AND THEN I LIVE IN A LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
BACKGROUND THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME IS
MADELINE EVAN DUDA AND I
REPRESENT SPCC AND THE FAMILIES
OF THE VICTIMS APRIL AND BEGAN
A LOT AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
FIND IT IN YOUR HEART TO PASS
A- LAW AB THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
PAIR MIKE IT'S OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARIA PHILLIPS I
REPRESENT THE OUR ETHICS
PROGRAM BUT IF YOU SEE A WOMAN
SINCE I LIVE IN TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONG YOUR
SUPPORT SB THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
ONE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IT UP.
HI MY NAME IS NOT A LEVY THAT
I'M WITH SPCC I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF WEST COVINA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE YOUR MY GET
UP AND. HELLO MY NAME IS FATIMA
KOREAN AND IRANIANS SB SIXTY. I
LIVING LOMITA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. ONE THREE HUNDRED
SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. I AM
THREE HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE. I'M THREE HUNDRED TWO
YOUR MIKE IT UP. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARIA PICCOLO- A CONCERNED
PARENT AND TEACHER I REPRESENT
AT THE TO SEE A LITTLE BOOK ON
THE FIELD AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY- ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS- LAW. AB THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE THERE
MIGHT GET UP. HELLO MY NAME IS
JONATHAN FORTE I REPRESENT AT
BCC I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
BELLFLOWER CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLINDS THREE HUNDRED SIX YOUR
MIKE IS UP. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARATHON GAL I EVEN CANNOT PARK
ON THE BLUE BOOK SB DC UNITED
NEIGHBORHOOD CANNOT PARK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHT PP ONE
THREE STOCKTON LOST THE ABUSE.
AND STOPPED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BLIND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS TED O'CONNOR SAID I AM
ONE SB SIX PM SEVEN CREATING
NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY OF WILMINGTON AND I'M
CALLING IT'S WRONG SB THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU YOU. BLIND TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS IN
OUR MARTINEZ I'M REPRESENTING
OUR CARTOON GROUP I LIVING I'M
CLARK THANK YOU NEXT JOHN WOULD
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHY NOT DO YOU
NINETY. I OPEN. YEAH. THE
FLIGHT TWO HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MIKE THIS OPEN. HI NINE DOES
NOT I MEAN THAT'S I'M WITH S.
B. V. I LIVE IN THE STATE OF
LOS PLANET I'M NOT WRONG A PART
OF AB ONE. THANK YOU. WHY DO I.
TWENTY HI MY NAME IS PAULA
THANK. YOU SEE OUR- BOB. OKAY.
THREE ONE. WE ARE TRYING TO
ISOLATE. THAT NOISE- YOU'RE
WELCOME- RIGHT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY. YOU MIGHT GET SOME.
THANK COULD ARGUE CANYON ALWAYS
NEXT FIFTY ELEGANT GARDEN AND I
AM INFO SUPPORT OF AB. INTO.
THANK YOU. IN THE LINE IT WITH
TWO HUNDRED NINETY AND MIKE
IT'S OPEN BECAUSE GOOD. THANK
YOU NINETY NINE PER YEAR MAKE
IT UP. WE CAN. HELLO YEAH YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. I CAN'T KID GO
AHEAD CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
WENDY TO HEAR. I'M REPRESENT SB
FIFTY AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORT
WITH THAT. AB THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. END OF LINE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROBERT
SHORT AND- I REPRESENT SPCC
INVESTOR PALMDALE- I LIVE IN
LIKE LOS ANGELES IN CONGO AND-
AS A PROUD FATHER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN GRAHAM
AND I REPRESENT I THINK FIFTY I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF LA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. AN ADELINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. YOUR MY KIDS
UP AT. HELLO MY NAME IT MIGHT
BE A CONSCIOUS SOMEONE
ORGANIZES THE OUTLOOK VALLEY AT
FIFTY THREE AND I LIVE IN
PALMDALE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB THIRTY ONE AND THAT ARE YOU.
AT THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN A
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MIKE
IS A- MY NAME'S DONALD MORROW
AND I REPRESENT THIRTY SECONDS
OF PROGRAMS THAT FIFTY THREE
AND I FROM THE PARKING LOT IF
YOU CAN'T. WINE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS LESLIE A FIGURE THAT
I LIVE IN THE CITY OF ONE CAN I
BE BACK WRITING TOGETHER WITH
EQUITY FEET I REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
ON YOUR UPCOMING COMMITTEE
HEARING. THANK YOU. YOU. ONE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ANIL
LIVING STONE I REPRESENT THAT
START REGION FIVE LANCASTER I
LIVE IN LIKE LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I'D STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX I COULD OPEN.
ONE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES CALLER GO AHEAD
PLEASE. OKAY I'M SORRY MY NAME
IS KELLY SALLY I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF MULTIMEDIA AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE AND
I'M WITH THE ORGANIZATION OF
FPTP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
THREE HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOUR
MICROSCOPE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SAID TO HAVE ASKED IF
YOU CAME NIGHT TRIP WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE SEA AND I
LIVE IN THE AREA OF THE FOUNDER
AND THE CONGOLESE SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE. THE YOU FOR. LINE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY TWO YOUR
MIKE IT'S OPEN. MY NAME IS MY
NAME IS KENNY OUT TOMORROW NO.
ARBUS AND ACTUALLY SHE SHE I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF HAWTHORNE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAKE IT UP AND. HI MY NAME IS
ADMITTEDLY I REPRESENT SB CC
AND THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS
GABRIEL AND PIANOLA I LIVE IN
LA AND STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX FOR MY COULD
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARGARITA
HELLO I REPRESENT AT THE AND
THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS
GABER FERNANDEZ I LIVE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE YOUR MY GET UP.
THANK TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
YOUR MIKE IS UP. ONE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE YEAH
MIKE IT'S OPEN. HOWEVER MANY
REFERRING SILVA AND I REPRESENT
STCC I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
CARSON AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU WE
WILL FIND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TINA
LOUISE I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH I'M A COMMUNITY
BASED DOULA WITH STRENGTH BASED
COMMUNITY CHANGE IN THE STRONG
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU. WINDS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX MIKE IT'S UP IN. HI MY NAME
IS ASHLEY ALEXANDER AND I AM
SUPPORTING. FAMILIES OF GABRIEL
FERNANDEZ ANTHONY ABA LISTEN
NOT CRACKED SHELL AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT SB THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. I AM THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE YOUR MIKE IT'S UP.
HI MY NAME IS KARINA MARTIN I
REPRESENT SPCC I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF TORRANCE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU. FIVE THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS UP. FIND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN- MY KIDS UP IN
PLAYTECH COMMIT. AND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JASMINE WE MALARKEY I
REPRESENTED BASICALLY AND THE
FAMILIES OF GABRIEL FERNANDEZ
ANTHONY ENVELOPE AND ALL
QUALTROUGH I LIVE IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE YEAR
MIKE ECHO. HELLO YES I CAN HEAR
YOU. MY NAME IS KELLY ARE GOING
WELL I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
COMPTON AND I FAMILIES AT FIFTY
THREE CRITICAL ABOUT WHAT I
SUPPORT THIRTY ONE AND YOUR
COMING TO HEARING. THANK YOU.
AND ALLOW THAT THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN LIKE A UP. ALL NINE
THREE HUNDRED FOR FIVE YOUR
MIKE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS REMOTE
NON I SB THE THING I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF YOUR- AND STRONGLY
AB. THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED
TWO YOU'RE MY UP. THIS. ONE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO YOUR
MIKE IT'S UP. HELLO MY NAME IS
ONE OF MANY VOEPEL I REPRESENT
SB FIFTY FIVE EFFECTIVE WILL
THAT COME FROM I LIVE IN TAMPA
I STRONG ENOUGH TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. HELLO YES
I CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA BANG I
AM THE AIR ANTHONY ALL THE LONG.
AND AND REPRESENTS THE CBCP AND
THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS
GABRIEL FAMILY AND THE FAMILY
AND OUR FAMILY I LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA CITY A STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE PLEASE
HELP US MAKE A CHANGE WE CAN
HELP BUT- BRING. MORE TO THE
EXTENT KNOWING THAT THESE NEW
LAW CAN BE PASSED ON TO MY%
CHILDREN HAVE TO DIE LIVING
WITH FIFTEEN IS TOO MUCH AND IF
WE CAN DO THEY CAN BREAK THEIR-
YOU CAN MAKE THINGS EASIER
FAMILIES TO COMMUNICATE HIS. TO
SAVE OUR CHILDREN PLEASE WE
REALLY NEED BATES AND WE'RE-
WE'RE BEGGING YOU GUYS LIKE I.
WE NEED SUPPORT AND WE NEED TO
PASS THIS STATE ALL IS GOING TO
SAVE SOME CHAU. AND WE NEED TO
STAND BY OUR CHILDREN BE OUR
FUTURE AND NEED TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. AND WINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. WELL.
I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY. IT'S
OKAY OPERATOR. NINE THREE SIX
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY
LINE TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE.
AND I WILL PERCENT IF YOU SEE
IF APARTMENT FROM THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH AND I SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY
CHAU I WAS THAT UNIQUE GARDEN
WHAT SPCC I LIVE IN LONG BEACH
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SANDY ON THE BALLOT I
REPRESENT S. B. P. AND I LIVE
IN THE CITY OF DOWNEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE TO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALSO THE
BIGGEST I REFER SAID
CONVENIENCE BUT I WILL ONLY
THAT ONLY THAT FROM IS. THANK
YOU RYAN THREE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEX SAY REPRESENT SPCC I LIVE
IN THE CITY OF DOWNEY AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOUR
OR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JESSICA CARMICHAEL I
REPRESENT AS FIFTY THREE I LIVE
IN WILMINGTON AND I STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ZERO NINE
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
SILENCE AND I REPRESENT STCC
AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B. THIRTY ONE THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR A THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NINE AREAS I REPRESENT STCC AND
I LIVE IN THE CITY OF CARSON
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NIKOS
CLOSER REPRESENTS THE S. B. C.
THING I LIVE IN SPECULAR
CALIFORNIA MY SON WAS SUPPORT
SB THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR- I DO NOT
SEE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM WE HAVE A NO SUPPORT
IN THE V. W. R. ROOM OPERATOR
HE SAID IS THERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ONLINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
FOR IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST LINE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. AN OPERATOR
JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS IS.
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE CORRECT.
I'M DAVE SHOULD UP WHEN I SAID
OPPOSITION SO THE SHOULD BE
OPPOSITION OKAY. THANK YOU.
WHAT TRYING NINE FOUR SEVENTEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
OUT. YOU AMONG THE PUBLIC FOR
THIRTY ONE OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU.
TRYING TO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO LINO MARYLAND OKAY
THE NEW YORKER THE SIMPLICITY
FIFTY ONE MINS PHONE THEY ONE
LISTED ON THE COUNCIL YEAH OR
YOU'LL GET A MOMENT THEN LET ME
FIVE EIGHT THREE THANK YOUNG WE
CHECK IT OUT HERE. BUT I SEE
THANK YOU. THREE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR WHAT TRIBE
RIGHT THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE NUMBER THREE SEVEN LANDERS
PRESENTS LEAKING HE AND I LONG.
THE LITTLE FOR YEAH YOUR FEET
MAY MANDATE EIGHT DOT. ONE AND
IF HE'S- RIGHT ARE NOW PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE ZERO NINE
YOU MAY HAVE YOUR NEW WHICH. OR
TRIED TO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ANOTHER
I LIVE IN THE CITY OF WOMEN
CAN'T REPRESENT DRIVING
TOGETHER WITH SB THE IRISH
COURT I REQUEST THAT YOU BOTH.
AB THIRTY ONE YOU'RE UP. THANK
YOU. NINE THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE SIX ZERO. YOU.
NINE THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THE THREE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY YEAH MY NAME IS
A MOTHER BOARD OF LOS. OUR
REPRESENT AB FIFTEEN IN ABOUT
THE LAST NAMES I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS AFTER OUR BELIEF THAT SB AND
I LIVE ONLY TEN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE MILLION
SEVEN MOST VALUABLE WITHIN OUR
PRESENT TIME TO GATHER SB KIKI
AND I ACTUALLY AT THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANKS OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NEAR ME I'M A SENIOR CENTER
PERCENT NOT I'M. I'M NOT AND
EVERYTHING AND I IT'S A SUPPORT
AB THIRTY THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD. HELLO. GOT
THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. GO AHEAD HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. MAN NUMBER
THERE'S BUT ANNIKA WILL BETTER.
THE PRESIDENT DIETER AB FIFTY
AN HOUR LONGER THAN BE ABLE TO
LOOK BACK LOOK OUT FOR YOU IN
MOMENT- AB. THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU. YEAH THANK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT COMMENT.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME WITH THE
LUCAS DELIGHTED WITH THE CITY
OF COMPTON AND NINE I TRULY. I
WOULD LIKE THIS CLOCK TO PASS
THE AB THIRTY ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. NO OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. AT SOMEONE
DAVIS THANK YOU MR LACKEY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
UP IT'S LONG OVERDUE AND I
WOULD BE HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MR THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBER LACK FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- CERTAINLY AND I
WANT TO THANK THE RESIDENTS
FROM COMPTON. FOR S. B. C. C.
FROM COMPTON BLOOMINGTON
TORRANCE- COMPTON LOS ANGELES
THAT I REPRESENT AND
SUPPORTING- THE SENATE BILL
THIRTY ONE- AND I WOULD LIKE TO
BE CONSIDERED JOINT ON THIS
BILL IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANYONE I
WOULD LOVE TO. BE WITH YOU-
FISTING GLOVES AS AS BILL MOVED
TO LESS THAN A PROCESS I THINK
IT ABSOLUTELY NEEDED- WE'VE ALL
HEARD ABOUT- THIS YOUNG MAN AND
THE HORRIFIC- TRAGEDY THAT
HAPPENED TO HIM AND- SO THIS
IS- YOU KNOW WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO STOP. ANY
KIND OF ABUSE TAKING PLACE FOR
OUR MOST AFFORDABLE THAT'S OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE- WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
CHILDREN'S- THEY SHOULD BE
HONORED TO HAVE CHILDREN AND
ALSO IF THE KIDS ARE GOING
INTO. SOME KIND OF PROGRAM IS
FOSTER CARE WHATEVER THOSE
GUARDIANS SHOULD BE RECHARGE
THEIR CHARGES POSSIBILITY OF
SAFEGUARDING THOSE CHILDREN AND
MAKING SURE THEY ARE SAFE. AND
SECURE. AND I YOU KNOW- IT'S-
BROKE HEART HERE. A THIS ON THE
NEW- WOULD. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP WE KNOW THAT
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY EMOTIONALLY.
I THINK WE ARE ALWAYS EMOTIONAL
EMOTIONAL- BY YOU BRING THIS
BILL BOARD BUT ALSO YOUR
CONNECTION TO THIS. IT IS
PERSON TO PERSON TO EVERYONE
HAS CHILDREN- AND TO EVERY
ADULT- CERTAIN TO YOUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE MINES
AND SO- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS HAPPILY TODAY. THANK YOU
SIR AND HERE ON OUT THANK YOU.
OKAY IN AND I JUST WANT ALSO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUES- THE
STATEMENT SAID THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. I
KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT FOR YOU
M. TO GET THROUGH THIS AND- WE
APPRECIATE YOU YOUR COURAGE.
THANK YOU SIR I BELIEVE WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. JUST
JUST WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY
SAYING THIS REGIONAL HONORS OUR
LOST CHILDREN. WITH AN ADVOCATE
FOR PROTECTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES. DAVIES I ARAMBULA.
CHOI AYE CHU AYE AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON ICE DOWN STONE I BELIEVE
THAT. WARRANTY LORD HI THANK
YOU VERY SIXTIES ERA. THANK YOU
MISTER MARKEY. AT THE MOMENT
MAJORITY LEADER REYES. TRY TO
PRESENT.
I HAD. AB NINETY TWO.
YES ALL RIGHT I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY I PRESENT TO
YOU AB NINETY TWO WHICH WILL
CREATE AN EQUITABLE SLIDING
SCALE FOR FAMILY FEES THAT WILL
ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN ON WORKING
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
CHILD CARE. CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE STATES
FOR PARENTS WHO NEED CHILD CARE
SERVICES. WELL THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF STATE OR FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS THAT HELP
FAMILIES PAY FOR CHILD CARE
FAMILIES WHO NEED TO CARE MUST
STILL PAY WHAT IS CALLED FAMILY
FEES. THESE FEES GROWERS INCOME
ARISES AND CAN BE UP TO SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
MONTH. WHICH IS UNAFFORDABLE
FOR MANY WORKING FAMILIES. THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY HEIGHTENED THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE.
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING MOTHERS
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
ARE SIGNIFICANT PART OF CHIP
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL WERE FOR
WORKFORCE. IN LIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
ECONOMIC RECESSION PARENTS NEED
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE NOW MORE
THAN EVER IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
AB NINETY TWO WILL ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BY CONVENING A
WORK GROUP OF PARENTS.
PROVIDERS CHILD CARE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND OTHERS TO
DEVELOP AN EQUITABLE SLIDING
SCALE FOR FAMILY FEES THAT
BETTER REFLECTS THE FAMILY'S
BUDGET. THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY
ENSURING THEY DO NOT ABSORB THE
COST OF A REDUCTION IN FAMILY
FEES. AND THAT THE NUMBER OF
CHILD CARE SPACES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NOT REDUCED. AND FINALLY AB
NINETY TWO WILL UTILIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING TO TEMPORARILY WAIVE
FAMILY FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES
UNTIL OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. TO REDUCE THE HARDSHIP OF
COVERED NINETEEN CALIFORNIANS
AND AS PERMITTED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
BECAUSE A LOT MORGAN A PARENTS
PAYING HIGH FAMILY FEES FOR
CHILD CARE AND LORI FURSTENFELD
WITH THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER.
THANK YOU MS RANTS OPERATOR CAN
YOU OPEN THE LINE FOR MISS
MORGAN. OPENDAYLIGHT HELLO. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MAKAYLA MARTIN AND I'M A
MOTHER TO A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
AND TWO YEAR OLD AND CURRENTLY
A FOUR POINT OH GRADUATE
STUDENT PURSUING TWO MASTER'S
DEGREE OF THE MARRIAGE FAMILY
THERAPIST I AM BILINGUAL SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST HERE IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA I'M IN CENTRAL
WORKER WORKING WITH STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND A MEMBER
OF CAN'T WAIT THEN. I WILL
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE WAITING
LISTS FOR OVER A YEAR THERE
WERE ONE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AHEAD OF MY SON WAITING FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE MY
COMMUNITY ALONE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WAITING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I MISSED SO MANY
NIGHTS NOT BEING ABLE TO BE TO
PUT MY BABY TO SLEEP BECAUSE I
WAS WORKING NIGHT I THANK THEM
FOR EACH TRACK RECORDS THANKS
TO THE CHARACTER AND THE
ACTIONS TAKEN BY OUR STATE I
WAS ABLE TO GET IN THE CENTRAL
WORK HEALTHCARE VOUCHER. QUIT
MY SECOND JOB FOCUSED ON SCHOOL
AND GET ON MY BACK THE MY BABY
CAN FALL ASLEEP IN MY ARMS
DURING THIS CRAZY YEAR I NEEDED
HIS SUPPORT AS MUCH AS HE
NEEDED MY EXPRESSION IN MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WHEN HE
WHEN HE WAS NINE YEARS OLD HE
BECAME EXTREMELY ILL DUE TO
CONTRACTING HOLDEN NINETEEN
SMALL THOUGH I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE VOUCHER I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
I WOULD HAVE TO PAY A FAMILY
FOR THE SUBSIDY. IT'S THREE
HUNDRED PER MONTH SOMEONE MIGHT
THINK THAT THREE HUNDRED IS IN
A LOT TO PAY FOR CHILD CARE BUT
WE ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK I HAVE MAPPED OUT ON
STUDENT LOANS AND CREDIT CARDS
MY HUSBAND ANOTHER SOCIAL
WORKER HAVE A LONG COMMUTE SO A
LOT OF MONEY GOES. TO HIS GAP.
CHECK THE CHANGE FOR IRAQ. I
BONTA PAYMENT PLAN WITH PJ. IN
ORDER TO MUCH CARE B. I'M AND
HAVING RIP. A LECTURE. IN ORDER
TO PAY FOR TO CARE. IT NEEDS
FOR LYNN. I NHà THAT BRING
DOLLARS IN NEED. PACKED UP ALL
MY BILL. AND MAKE ME FEEL
EMBARRASSED TO BE BONTA. PAIN
MY BILL THE- TO HOW I MY IN A
OF ALL MY- AND BEING. MY FAMILY.
TO FIND. MY CHAIR CARE CHILD
CARE PROVIDE. LIKE SAM TO ME. I
MISTER REDUCES PAYCHECK AND- MY
FAMILY YOU CAN MAKE THE DAY.
SHE OUR- AND SENATE. COP SHE
CAN'T EVEN UP. I FEEL MORE
BECAUSE IT DON'T PAY MY- I TAKE
MONEY OUT OF SANTA POCKET AND
I'LL END UP LOSING MY CHILD
CARE. GEN IF I KNEW CHECK FOR
MY- I RECALL AND SHE ME KNOW
HE'S OK THIS COULD ARGUE THE
CARD FACT DOT. HAVE GIVEN UP
THE SHOW WINDOW TO TAKE ACTION
TO WAIVE FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES
NOW. AB NINETY TWO WILL ALLOW
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES TO PAY NO
FEE FOR CHILD CARE AND HIGHER
INCOME FAMILIES. OKAY A LITTLE
MORE SO THAT EVERYONE CAN GET
ACT MONTHLY FROM THEIR ABILITY
TO PAY. YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THE WAY THINGS WORK WE
HAVE ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS WHAT'S HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. AND BRING
EQUITY CHARGE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. I YES I YES AB THIRTY
TILL AND THAT'S- ABOUT THE
COURT CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES. ESSENTIAL. WORKERS
LIKE ME. THEY YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN OPEN THE LINE FOR
LAURIE FIRST IN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERY CHILD TO GROW UP A LOVING
HEALTHY I READY CAN THRIVE AND
EVERY PARA HAS THE TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR- I'M LAURIE
FURSTENFELD CO DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY
AT THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER. AB
NINETY TWO IS A PANDEMIC REALLY
FILLED THAT IMMEDIATELY PUTS
MONEY BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF
FAMILIES IN CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR. AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
TEMPORARILY WAY FAMILY FEES FOR
ALL FAMILIES WITH THE PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES
THERE AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY THIS
SOLUTION ALLOWED PARENTS WHO
WERE ESSENTIAL WORKERS TO KEEP
WORKING AND ENSURE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS COULD STAY OPEN BY
PAYING THEM IN FULL. FROM
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FAMILY FEES ARE WAIVED ONLY
FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE NOT
SENDING THEIR CHILDREN TO CHILD
CARE DUE TO KOBE. UNDER THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY RELIEF
FUNDING LAWS WE NOW HAVE A
NARROW WINDOW TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE ALL
FAMILIES RELIEF FROM THE FAMILY
FEES NOW FIRST THIS BILL
TEMPORARILY WAY FAMILY FEES FOR
ALL FAMILIES UNTIL OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO REDUCE THE HARDSHIPS OF THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SECOND
CONFEDERAL CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT ACT THE
MAIN SOURCE OF FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA
MANDATES THAT THE REQUIRED
FAMILIES MUST BE AFFORDABLE AND
NOT A BARRIER TO FAMILIES
RECEIVING CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE. IN CALIFORNIA THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN AFFORDABLE FOR
YEARS AND THE PANDEMIC HAS
GREATLY ELEVATED HOW
UNAFFORDABLE FAMILY FEES AND
PARKLET TNX. BLACK IN OTHER
FAMILIES OF COLOR. THEREFORE
EIGHTY NINETY CAN BE THE
WORKING GROUP. CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS STATE STAFF AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE AN
EQUITABLE SLIDING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES ONCE THE REQUIRED
FAMILY FEES GO BACK INTO A
FACT. AB NINETY TWO IS MODELED
AFTER THE FEDERAL CHILD CARE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES ACT A BILL
INTRODUCED INTO CONGRESS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. IMPORTANTLY
AB NINETY TO PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY ENSURING THEY DO
NOT ABSORB THE REDUCTION AND
FAMILY FEES. AND THAT THE
NUMBER OF CHILD CARE SPACES NOT
REDUCED THANK YOU AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS
FURSTENFELD OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT
ON THE LINE. OR COULD IT HAVE
BEEN A- SEVEN THE CLOSE OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DONNA CULLEN AND
REPRESENTING COUNCIL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA READY NATION
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS AND
MISSION READINESS. AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT EIGHTY NINETY
YEAH THANK YOUNG THANK YOU. AND
THE O. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI A- THIS IS KATHY DOWN ALL
STAND REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION AND
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE. LINE TWO HUNDRED ONE YOUR
MIKE IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DANIELLE ONE DRUG WITH
CHILDREN NOW CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN YOU'RE MY COULD HELP.
HI MY NAME IS MARK ONE I AM A
REGULAR TOPIC CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF COUNTY BOARD BECAUSE
AND I QUOTE EIGHTY NINE YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI THIS IS JASON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SOME COUNCIL- I'M ALSO A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT- FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS GLADYS ALSO CHAIR OF
PLANNING WHICH IS SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT CHAPTER AND I'M IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTING A. B.
NINETY TWO PLEASE VOTE JANICE
ON AT NINETY TWO. THANK YOU.
WINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY YOUR
MICROSCOPE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE SLICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY TWO. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FOR YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MONNING UP A LOT
OF GOOD REPRESENTING PLACE JUST
SOUTH OF FISCAL AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONICA MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE FOR MY COULD OPEN. LITTLE
HERNANDEZ I REPRESENT PARENTS
VOICES FRESNO AND I SUPPORT AB
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY TO HEAR
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
INTERNET BIRTH THIS IS BILLY
MCKAY ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
LA IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE. YOU MIGHT
GIVE UP AND- KATIE WATER
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND WE ARE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SIX FOR
MY COULD OPEN. SH HI THIS IS
POLICY MANUAL I AM WEST-
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG OF
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY NINE IN MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS
GEOMETRY ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
SUPPORTERS EIGHTY NINE TO TWO.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS UP. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON HM DALY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK APPROACH-
BONTA THE BILL ANYTIME SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX YOUR MIKE IT'S UP. FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY PICK YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. ONLY NUMBER. OF AYE YAY
BUT AYE FONG BELONG ON THE
FOOTBALL. TEAM THE ONE ON THE
CALIFORNIA YEAH YOU COULD THE
L. DEEPENING YOUR. THANK YOU.
LINE HOW SEVENTY MIKE IS A- HI
CALLING PAD ON BEHALF OF THE
LEFT UNTIL YOU SCHOOL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS APRIL
YANG AND I AM WITH TERRIBLY
DIFFERENT BILL AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. AB NINETY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE YOUR BIKE IT'S OPEN.
THANK YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO
HEAD. OUT HI I'M CALLING FROM
SAN MATTEO COUNTY PARENT VOICES
CHAPTER MY NAME IS BRENDA
GONZALEZ AND WE ARE STRONG IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY TWO IN
CAMP THANK YOU. LINE A FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE OR MIKE IT
UP. HELLO THIS IS NANCY WHY IT
WITH THE FAMILY CHILDCARE
NETWORK CALIFORNIA FAMILY
HEALTHCARE NETWORK AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU. BLIND FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COLD WAR GOLDMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT OF WILL BE NINETEEN.
THANK YOU. A LINE OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN YEAR MIKE
IS UP. HI JASON SOMEONE ON THE
CALIFORNIA ALL CREATED PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND ONE
STRONG SUPPORTER A. B. NINETY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS MY HOW MUCH I NEED I AM A
MEMBER OF A PARABLE TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY TWO. THANK
YOU. FIND FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX YOUR MARKETS OPEN.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
THANKS TWO HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT-
MIKE IS OPEN. AND I SHOW NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM I DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ON THE
LINE OPERATOR. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO COMMENT COMING THROUGH
THANK YOU OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISS DAVIS. THE
STRENGTH QUESTION FOR YOU CAN
JUST CLARIFY I KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE- WITNESSES HAD- MADE A
COMMENT THAT- OBVIOUSLY THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE PAYING BUT
THE- THOSE WITH HIGHER INCOMES
WOULD BE PAYING A LITTLE BIT
MORE. IS THAT THE FACT. THE
WAIVER WILL BE FOR ALL FAMILIES
THROUGH OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. OKAY SPEND ANY IDEA
HOW MANY WE THINK WE BUT MY
QUALIFY FOR THIS AND WHERE
WOULD THE FUNDING COME FROM.
IT'S THE ESTIMATE THAT'S BEEN
GIVEN THROUGH OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AND THIS
WOULD COME FROM THE- AT THE
ALLOCATION OF CALIFORNIA GETS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FOR THE CODED REALLY FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU WITH THAT I
WOULD WANT THE BILL. OKAY THANK
YOU. I DO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
MYSTERY SPECTRALLY US FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTRANSLATION AND WE HAVE A
MOTION MISS DAVIES FOR. THANK
YOU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES ALL RIGHT
ARAMBULA CHOI GIPSON STONE
STONE I'D THE LIKUD AT WARD THE
VOTERS THREE TO ZERO OKAY YEAH
I HAVE MISSED THIS BILL WILL
STAND CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER AT MAJORITY LEADER
REYES WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE UP
AB FORTY SEVEN YES THANK YOU.
AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO CREATE A
COORDINATED EFFICIENT AND
HOLISTIC RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS
OF IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AFFECTED
BY BORDER A SEPARATION. IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT AT LEAST TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED THAT CHILDREN WERE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER MANY OF
WHOM UPON REUNIFICATION. HAVE
SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA THE ACT
OF SEPARATING A PARENT FROM THE
CHILD IS CRUEL AND TRAUMATISING
FOR BOTH PARENT AND CHILD. IN
ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY AID AND
DRESSING THE TRAUMA INFLICTED
BY THIS PRACTICE WE MUST ENSURE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES HAVE
THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET. AB FORTY
SEVEN AIMS TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM THE CONNECTS
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AFFECTED
BY BORDER SEPARATION WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES THAT
ENCOMPASS THE FULL SCOPE OF
FAMILIES NEEDS. THROUGH
ASSISTANCE OF QUALIFIED
NONPROFITS. SUCH A PROGRAM
WOULD ALLOW FOR NONPROFITS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
OUR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO HOUSING SERVICES.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND FOOD
AND GROCERY RESOURCES LEGAL
RESOURCES AND MORE. AS WE
TRANSITION OUT OF. THE TRUMP
ERA THERE IS A NEED IT TO HAVE
A POLICY CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
WE SUPPORT OUR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS JOHANNA
THE BARBARA'S AND SEND THAT
WITH SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES
AND MARIO PEREZ WITH INLAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE.
THANK YOU YOUR DAILY RANTS
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR JOHANNA NEVADA
POOREST. IN BOTH WITNESS LINES
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU TO CHECK ON THAT ON A
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
JOHANNA NAVARRO PEREZ I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PELOPONNESE COMING UP
PROGRAM AT SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES. NATIONALLY OFTEN FROM
MEDIA LOCATE FAMILIES ENACTED
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FAMILY SEPARATION POLICY I
CONNECT THEM TO MY FATHER FACT
MAINTENANCE SERVICES WE COULD
NOT DO THIS WORK WITHOUT
PARTNERING WITH THE NATIONAL
NETWORK OF EXISTING CARE
PROVIDERS. LIKE KIDS IN NEED OF
THE FENCE. AND A LOCAL LEVEL.
AND TODAY TO ENCOURAGE. AFTER
SUPPORT EXISTING THAT COUNTY
FOR THE LONG EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
WILL CONTINUE THE WORK OF
BRINGING NEEDED MEDICAL HELP
AND BASIC NEEDS SERVICES TO
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY THE ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY WHO NOW
RESIDES IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS GROUP IS NOT
AMONG BLACK LIKE ALL FAMILIES
HAVE EXPERIENCED A TRAUMA
THEY'RE WRITING THEIR OWN
HEARING STORIES BUT FOR MANY
MANY FIFTY AMERICA HEALTH
URGENT IN THE COMING MORE
CRITICAL FAMILY THINK A
COORDINATED INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICES IN THEIR REGION THIS
CARE MIGHT BE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE IN TRAUMA INFORMED.
IN OUR WORK THAT FAMILIES AND
TACTIC BY THE DEAL TOLERANCE
POLICY NATIONALLY MOMS AND DADS
ARE NOT FOLLOWING THE
UNIFICATION THEIR CHILDREN ARE
STRUGGLING PHYSICALLY AND
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAYS WEEKS
MONTHS AND YEARS AFTER
REUNIFICATION AB FORTY SEVEN
WILL LEVERAGE AND ORGANIZED
EXISTING CARE PROVIDERS
PROVIDING THIS RESPONSE TO OUR
STATE BUILT AROUND AN
ACCEPTABLE TOLL FREE ONE LINE.
WE MUST KEEP SHOWING UP FOR
THESE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THERE ARE FRIENDS OF OUR FAMILY
AND OUR NEIGHBORS ACTUALLY
CLOCKING FOR THAT REASON I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT ON. EIGHTY THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK MISTER
MONOPRIX- OPERATE CAN YOU OPEN
LINE FROM OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- HI THIS IS MARTY
PROTEST- COMMUNITY ORGANIZER-
WITH THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
NETWORK- FOR THE- IN COALITION
KARMACOIN JUSTICE- I AM A FIRST
RESPONDER- AND SO I HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND- THE
NEEDS AND SERVICES UP O'CONNOR
COMING AND- ESPECIALLY MINORS
AND MIGRANT FAMILIES- AS A OF
THE COALITION IN YEMEN AT THE
COALITION I SAID JAMIE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT- AB FORTY
SEVEN- ARE YOU WE HAVE- WE TEND
TO PARTY OUR MINORS- AND
FAMILIES AND WE KNOW THE NEED
FOR THE SERVICES- MOST RECENTLY
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN
FAMILIES WERE- BEING DROPPED
OFF AND- AT THE GREYHOUND
STATION AND FROM THERE YOU KNOW
WE WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT-
LARGELY DEPENDING ON COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT. CREATE A
VOLUNTEERS AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AND SO IF YOU FORTY
SEVEN WOULD BE- TENEMENTS
SUPPORT- FOR YOU KNOW- CONTINUE
TO CONTINUING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PEOPLE- AND WE LARGELY
APPRECIATE MAJORITY MAJORITY
NEAR- ELOISE RADIUS FOR SPOCK
SPONSORING THE BAIL- SHE HAS
WITNESSED FIRST HAND- YOU KNOW
THE NEED FOR THE SERVICE SAYS-
FACILITIES FOR A COMPANY MINERS
ARE OPENING UP IN OUR STATE
INCLUDING. IN OUR REGION WHICH
THE TOP MONA- AND THE STATE
SHOULD- YOU KNOW AS HUMAN AND
YOU KNOW THE- WE SHOULD BE ABLE
WELCOME. AND COMPASSIONATE. AND
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ANY AND ALL
SERVICES NEED IT AND A. B.
FORTY SEVEN REPORT COMPLETELY
BEING- THE POTENTIAL FOR THAT-
ON A PERSONAL NOTE- I
PERSONALLY MET THE FAMILY THE
MINERS THAT ARE SEEKING REFUGE-
THEIR FATE THERE BASIS AND LIKE
THEIR STORIES- ARMED BEHALF LET
A LONG LANKY. ALONG LONG
ENOUGH- IMPRESSION- ON ME ON MY
CELL IN ORGANIZER AND- I KNOW
THAT THERE IS A DOCTOR NEEDS
SPORT FOR THE SERVICES
INCLUDING. AGAIN I WITNESS A
TRAUMA FIRST HAND. AND YOU KNOW
IT IS URGENT CORRECTIVE SUPPORT
FROM MINERS AND FAMILIES- FOR A
BETTER LIFE AND- JUST TO. BE
ABLE TO BE THERE FOR THEM TO.
YOU KNOW- SUPPORT THEM AGAINST
THE PERSECUTION AND INJUSTICE
AT THE PLANT- IN THE COUNTRIES-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR PRESS.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE LINE
OPERATOR. OR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND. FORTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADRIAN
SHELTON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN THAT
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY KID UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALES WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED ONE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS DANIELLE
ONE DRUG WITH CHILDREN NOW
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
LINE OF FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR MICROSCOPE. BOB
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS QUICKLY
CLAIM ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE TWO HUNDRED SIX YOUR
MY KIDS UP AT. THANK YOU THIS
IS AMBER SHE'D WITH KERR
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN A LINE OF FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LAST.
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR TO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. OR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB FORTY SEVEN
EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AUTHOR. NO IF
SOMEONE APPROACH LIKE CLOSE HER
SPECTRAL YES FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON I CALDERON I'D DAVIES.
DAVE IS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
CHOI GIPSON STONE STONE I WILL
PUT UP. THE LIKUD II WARD.
THANK YOU- SOMEONE WILL RAISE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE A BE
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE YES THANK
YOU THANK. AB FORTY SIXTY ONE
SIX TO ENSURE IMMIGRANTS TO
QUALIFY FOR STATE AND LOCAL
BENEFITS DO NOT GO WITHOUT THE
CRITICAL SERVICES AND RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO REMAIN HEALTHY AS
THEY WAIT FOR UNITED STATES.
CITIZEN AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES APPROVAL OF THEIR
APPLICATIONS. CURRENTLY
APPLICANTS OF U. VISAS T. VISAS
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS SEEKS SEEKERS. AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT
PETITIONERS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
STATE AND LOCAL BENEFITS IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THESE SERVICES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MUST GIVE
NOTICE THAT THEY HAVE APPROVED
THEIR APPLICATION AND IT IS
THEN THAT APPLICANTS CAN
RECEIVE. SERVICES AS APPLICANTS
WOULD FOR THIS APPROVAL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THEY MAY GO
WITHOUT TO THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES. THE TIME IN WHICH THE
APPLICANT MIGHT GO WITHOUT
SERVICES HAS ONLY INCREASED AS
THE RICH AS A PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED DELAYS IN THE
PROCESSING TIMES. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE WOULD ALLOW YOU TV'S
THE ASYLUM SEEKERS AND
QUALIFIED WOMEN AND YOUTH TO
ACCESS STATE AND LOCAL
RESOURCES ONCE THEY FILE THEIR
APPLICATION. WITH THE U. S. C.
I. C. EFFECTIVELY CLOSING THE
GAP IN WHICH AN APPLICATION MY
GO WITH AN APPLICANT MIGHT GO
WITHOUT SERVICES. ENSURING THE
NEEDS OF APPLICANTS ARE MET.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. AND TO KEVIN AS
LINE IN WITH THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE BILL. THANK
YOU FROM A MEMBER. OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR MR SANCHEZ AND MR FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSE TO. A
QUESTION FROM OUR MOM POVERTY
THE PRODUCT YOU'RE A SPONSOR OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX CALIFORNIA
BECAME A LEADER IN NINETEEN S.
B. FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE BY THEN
SENATOR SHOULD KILL ALL TO
PROVIDE STATE AND LOCAL
SERVICES DAHLE DEPLOYMENT.
CENTER ACTING OF POLICY IN
ORDER PRACTICED NIGGLES FOR
HAVE A DE A GAP IN. BUT I'VE
BEEN VERY CRITICAL CRUCIAL FOR
QUALIFIED IMMIGRANTS WERE
EXPERIENCING CRISIS UNDER
LIGHTS. FOR EXAMPLE WE RECEIVED
REPORTS OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WERE SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BEFORE TO
CONTINUE LIVING IN UNFIT
CONDITIONS FOR EXTENDED PERIODS
OF TIME BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO OBTAIN SOCIAL SERVICE
AND- ALLOW THEM TO MOVE TO A
SAFE LOCATION FOR THEIR OWN
PROTECTION. OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE ALSO RECEIVED NUMEROUS
REPORTS OF THOSE SEEKING ASYLUM
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THE
PROPER SERVICES THAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
THE UNITED STATES WITH LITTLE
TO NOTHING OUT OF POCKET.
FELINA HOMES OUT OF FEAR
PROSECUTION OF THE APARTMENT
THE COMMITTED AGAINST THEM. AND
I'M GRAYSON SYSTEM A FIVE YOU
COME TO KNOW STATE FOR SOME
REASON OTHER REFUGEES. THAT
THEY'RE NOT PROVIDED THE SAME
AMOUNT TRANSPORT OF THE
COUNTERPARTS. AB FORTY SIXTY
ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SPEAKING OUT OF TURN ONE OF THE
RUBIO. AND CLOSE THE GAP IN
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED TO THEM
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMES FIRST. DURING THE
VOLATILE PATTERNS AND ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCE IN MY LIFE IS
FOR THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
OXFORD I BOTH SITTING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MONTEREY NUMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER. SANCHEZ ACT.
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE MY
NAME. I HAD TO STRUGGLE. THEIR
MY IS JOE EVAN YOU KNOW. I WANT
TO CALL. CALIFORNIA WILL
COLLECT. SOLUTIONS NUMBER PROP
WILL- WILL SPONSOR. AB
FOURTEEN. ONE THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE TO THE- VICTIMS OF ABUSE.
AND ALL- AND IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
OF SCHOOL BUT OF THE OF. ARE
DROPPING BIGELOW L. THE WOOD.
TO HELP. AND BEING. SUBJECTED
TO CONTINUE THE BILL. JUST
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION. M. WE NEED A GOOD
KID. WE NEED TO MAKE THEM
ECONOMIC HOLE SO THEY COULD
AVOID THE BILL STEPPED
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. THEN
THIS IS A WONDERFUL FILL. THEM
WITH URGENT RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITION PUBLIC
SUPPORT ON LINE. FOUR COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
A COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE.
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY DOWN OFTEN WITH THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE. FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE HOLD
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH-
LINE NUMBER. OKAY.
INTERESTING
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY.
AN OUTLINE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. HI YOU
MAIL FROM KIDS THAT NEEDED THE
FANS KIND AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SHOWING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR
I DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR.
TWO I SEE NO OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR- COMMITTEE. NO
MISS RANSOM TO LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. TO HAVE A
MOTION. SECOND OKAY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA CHOI.
GIPSON STONE STONE AYE
FILOPODIA. AYE MORD. VOTERS
FORTY ZERO OKAY THE BILL STAYS
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MAJORITY LEADER-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVAS WOULD YOU
LIKE 2% A. B. C. FORTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOROUGH EVALUATION
OF THIS BILL AND ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I AM
EXCITED TO PRESENT AB FORTY SIX
A CRITICAL USE LED MEASURES
SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT STATE
LAWMAKERS HEAR THE VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOU. AB FORTY SIX
WILL ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION
WHICH WILL BE COMPROMISED
SOLELY OF YOUTH AND FOCUS. ON
POLICY ISSUES THAT IMPACT YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. THE COMMISSION'S
DUTIES WILL INCLUDE EXAMINING
POLICY HOLDING MEETINGS WITH
YOUTH ADVOCATES AND THE PUBLIC
AND INVESTING IN CRITICAL USED
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY A WIDE
COALITION OF SPONSORS AND
REPRESENTS TATIAN OF THAT
COALITION I'M PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY. AND SHREW JASON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
AND KEN LEWIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COKE COALITION FOR
YOUTH. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE WITNESSES.
WITNESS LINES ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANCHORAGES ON AND I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION I AM FROM SAN MATEO
COUNTY BUT I CURRENTLY LIVE
HERE IN STOCKTON I ENTERED
POSTURE CARE AROUND FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND MY
DAD WAS A DRUG USER AND I CAN
GO MOTHER OFTEN RAISED MY THREE
SISTERS AND I ALONE UNTIL WE
ALL ENTERED FOSTER CARE. WHILE
IN CARE I HAD BUILT MANY.
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIP WITH
FOSTER YOUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. AND TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE A FEW OF THEM WITH YOU
ALL. I HAD A GOOD FRIEND IN
COLLEGE I MET THROUGH A
GUARDIAN SCHOLARS PROGRAM. SHE
WAS NO DIFFERENT FROM. ANYONE
HERE INTEL INTELLECTUALLY IN
BALBOA HER BELIEVE. KILLED BY
THE LEFT IS THAT YOU TAKE IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. AND
YOUR DEEPLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
HER FUTURE. BUT TWO DAYS AFTER
THANKSGIVING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
MY PAST WEEK TO LAW COLLEGE
PROGRAM ONCE YOU HAVE TALKED IN
COURT HOW. AND A BRITISH COURT
ROOM PROCEEDINGS. AND I THOUGHT
MY COLLEAGUES. DURING THE COST
FOR ME AS I SAT THERE IN THE
CHURCH BENCHES AND SHE FOR. THE
INMATE JUMPSUIT. LAST I HAD
HEARD OF HER SHE HAD GOTTEN
SEVEN YEARS AND WHEN SHE GOT
OUT ON PAROLE TO COME TO A DRUG
ADDICTION. ANOTHER ONE OF MY
CUT OF ANOTHER ONE. MY FOSTER
BROTHER. WHOM I SLEPT WITH FOR
TWO YEARS WHO HE AND I SPENT
COUNTLESS HOLIDAYS WITH. BUT
SIX FEET APART. YOU TOO
NEGLIGENT CARE OF MY FOSTER
MOTHER. HE DROWNED. AND I DON'T
THINK THE ON BUTTON OFF FIFTY A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION. IN
ADDITION. IN THAT SAME HOME- MY
SISTER'S FOSTER MY SISTER'S
ROOMMATE SO MY OTHER BOXERS
MISTER WOULD BEING SEXUALLY
ABUSED BY- MY- FOSTER MOTHER'S
BIOLOGICAL SON WITH TEN YEARS
OLDER THAN HER AND THEN WHEN MY
PARTNER AND I REPORTED IT TO
THEM BUT THEN. NOTHING WAS DONE.
ALTHOUGH MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES IN FOSTER CARE WERE
NOT ENTIRELY COOL. THE WORKING
ENTIRELY KIND EITHER. IN MY
FELLOW FOSTER BROTHERS IN YEARS
TO COME TO THE SYSTEMIC
INEQUITY THAT EXISTS TODAY IN
EDUCATION AND ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN PDF THAT
THE OFFICE OF THE INBOX PERSON
AND COMMUNITY CARE MARTIN FORM
AND WITH MENTAL HEALTH. IT IS A
SOBRE REMINDER THAT THE PATH.
THE QUALITY WILL BE ARGUE WITH
BUT IT STARTS WITH
REPRESENTATION. OUR FIVE IT'S A
MULTI FACETED ONE. AND ASSEMBLY
BILL FORTY SIX. WELL ALLOW IT'S
NOT JUST ANOTHER BILL IT'S
WONDERFUL WORKING POWER
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
WHO WAS A VICTIM OF THE FOSTER
CARE TO PRISON PIPELINE AS WELL
AS- WE- LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHIN. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR- OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN A LINE FOR MISS LEWIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LET'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF AB FORTY SIX
HAVE YOU HEARD EIGHTY FORTY SIX
WILL CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
EMISSION A STATEWIDE ADVISORY
BODY TO THE GOVERNMENT
COMPRISED SOLELY OF YOUR-
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEANINGFUL
YOU CAN. INPUT CAN INCREASE
ENGAGEMENT AND ORGANIZATIONAL
ACTIVITIES AND WHEN ADULTS
PERCEIVE YOUNG PEOPLE EVALUATE
WHAT RESOURCES THAT CAN FOR
MANY OF THE DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THEM. THEY ALSO SEE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE QUALITY
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE. EASY
WHY RECOGNIZES AND VALUES THE
IMPORTANCE THAT YOU POINT THEM
PROVIDING THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL IMPACT IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE. WHO SERVE ON OUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. A VERY GOOD BY
THE BOARD WE HAVE FOUND THE
THAT WOULD TO ENGAGE. ALLOW
WITH THE RE. RESULTING IN
PROGRAM AND- IF YOU HAVE OFTEN
TAKEN ON MORE ACTIVE ROLES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. I TOO OFTEN WE
FIND STATE ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE FAIL TO ENGAGE
THEM OR TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE THEY INTEND TO
SEARCH HE FORTY SIX A LOT OF
TWO OF THE STATE'S TOP BOX SO
THEY CAN ACHIEVE THE- INTENDED
OUTCOMES. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
BY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REDUCE YOUR CHAMPING AT THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME AND ATTENTION. TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LEWIS. OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE LINE. FOR
COMMENTED SUPPORT TO AB FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE IN MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE
BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WHINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED TWO WE ARE MY KIDS UP
IN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS STEPHANIE
IDLERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I FIVE HUNDRED THREE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIC MORSE OF
METROPOLITAN LINCOLN THE
ALLIANCE BOARD MEN OF COLOR WE
ARE COSPONSORED AND STRONG
SUPPORTER BABY FOR SIX. THANK
YOU. FIND FIVE HUNDRED FOR YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S HE
ARMED WITH THE EMPOWERMENT
COLLECTIVE AND I'M ALSO A
STUDENT FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY YOUR MY KIDS UP.
JERRY BRUCKHEIMER HAPPEN TO
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
YOU. BLIND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE- MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JORDAN
FELDSTEIN A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THAT CORN BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION NICKEL SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT OF P. P.
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU. AND FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CRITICAL
COUNTY ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THIS IS KELLY
HARDY WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE HUNDRED FIVE YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CAPTAIN THIS YEAR ON A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU. FIVE THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE OR MIKE IT'S
OPEN. AND YOU NEED TO SHARE
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA WEARING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BRIANNA WILLIS ON BEHALF OF
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JUSTIN CHON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
CITY COUNCIL- AND STUDENT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE PROP SPONSOR OF
THE BILL STRONG SUPPORT
ADDITIONALLY GENERATION OP
ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AN ONLINE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO YOUR MIKE IT'S UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF
UNDERSTANDING YOU CAN USE
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ON THROUGH
THE BILL CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HOW AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR AT THIS
TIME I SEE NO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ONLINE. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING FOR IT THANK YOU
OPERATOR AT THIS TIME I SEE NO
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM- DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER BILL PUT IT. TO THE
CHAIR THANK YOU I JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS. WHAT
I MEAN I'VE BEEN READING
THROUGH THIS AND WHAT A GREAT
DEAL SO I WAS I WAS HOPING THAT
YOU CAN ADD A SAYS A CO AUTHOR.
SURE I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO
JOIN ME ON THE BELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS SUMMER SURE YOU KNOW
I BELIEVE OUR DEMOCRACY. IS
BETTER SERVED WHEN YOUTH ARE
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
CONTRIBUTE THEIR UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVES- IN POLICY
DECISIONS THANK YOU. FOR
HEARING THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. TO HAVE A
MOTION. SHOULD SECOND. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
CHOI. GIPSON STONE STONE
ARAMBULA HUDA THE PUT I WARD.
THAT IS FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
MISS REAVIS YOUR BILLS DOWN
CALL THANK YOU. ALL. MR MILLER
PUT ME READY TO PRESENT ON AB
FOUR SIX ONE. ASIAN. SECOND.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS- AB
FOUR SIXTY ONE WILL REMOVE
BARRIERS FOR FAT CAL WORKS-
BENEFICIARIES TO USE SELF AN
APPOINTMENT AS AN OPTION OF
WELFARE TO WORK- ACTIVITIES BY.
RECALCULATING THEIR OUR SPENT
ON ONE'S SELF EMPLOYMENT
ACTIVITIES TO THE ACTUAL AMOUNT
OF HOURS SPENT ON THOSE
ACTIVITIES TODAY CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS ARE REQUIRED. TO
PARTICIPATE IN A WORK ACTIVITY
AND HAVE THEIR OWN. OPTION TO
PARTICIPATE IN WORK STUDY SELF
EMPLOYMENT IN IT INTERNSHIPS
COMMUNITY SERVICE JOB SKILLS
TRAINING IN VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION AMONG. OTHER
QUALIFIED ACTIVITIES. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY B. B. FOR
SIXTY ONE IS KEVIN- AS AS WHEN
IN THE SECULAR DIRECTOR
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION AND
CHRISTOPHER SANCIOUS POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND PROPERTY. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE WITNESSES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COULD PERCENT OF POPPED UP
ELECTIONS IN A LONG POVERTY
WILL PROBABLY BE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB FOUR SIX ONE TO
ENSURE THAT CHARACTERS HAVE
BEEN. ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE TOWN
POLITICAL POTENTIAL BY
ADJUSTING THE PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENT CALCULATION BUT PUBLIC
FUNDING HOURS IN RECENT YEARS
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE OF
THE FULLY EMBRACED ENTREPRENEUR
SPIRIT BY ENACTING LEGISLATION
I WAS REQUIRED NONTRADITIONAL
INDUSTRIES BUT I'VE BEEN LONG
PEOPLE BE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
SUCH AS LEGALIZATION OF STREET
VENDORS LEGALIZATION AND
PASSAGE OF THE HOMESTEAD FOOD
ACT UNDER THOUSAND OF MICRO
KITCHENS IN ADDITION TO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE LEGISLATION. ADRIN
OUR FOR THIRTY ONE BUILT UPON
THE SPIRIT BY CREATE BOTH UPON
THE SPIRIT BY CREATING MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR TOWERS
RECIPIENTS ACHIEVING THE TOP
EMPLOYMENT OPTION OF THE WORK
ACTIVITY REQUIREMENTS THIS IS
SPECIALLY CRITICAL DURING A
TIME WHEN OUR STATE TRANCE
RECOVERED FROM A PANDEMIC. TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE OF
FOSTERING THE ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY NOW MORE THAN EVER
CALIFORNIANS HAVE MORE OPTIONS
TO BECOME ENTREPRENEURS GIVEN
THE POLICY ADVOCATE LOVE THAN
MANY NOW WE HAVE TRANSPORT HOW
WE PROVIDE SERVICES- IN OUR
STATE. MANY FOOTBALL DIDN'T THE
STORY STARTED OUT IN CALIFORNIA
WITH ONE PERSON BEING A SOLE
PROPRIETOR WORKING OUT OF THE
HOME OR SPENDING A LITTLE MORE
TIME UTILIZING THEIR TALENTS
TURNER DEFINITELY COME. TO VOTE
VERY TIMELY A CALIFORNIA
THINKING OF INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
GENERATE REVENUE OF CALIFORNIA
GENERATE REVENUE FOR THE FALL
THE FAMILY AND TO TAKE THE
NEEDED READ TO. TO GET HIMSELF
OUT OF ALL POVERTY FOR THOSE
FAMILIES THAT ARE GOING ON
TODAY WE BELIEVE WE ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IN CALIFORNIA DREAMS
ALLOWED THEM TO CHOOSE THE BEST
OPTION FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND TO REMOVE
BARRIERS- FOR PUBLIC RECIPIENT
TODAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS INCLUDED ME THE OPTION
TO SPLIT. UP THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER LINUS. OPERATORS THE
LINE OPEN FOR NEXT WITH WITNESS.
YES- I'M ALREADY. YEAH THIS IS
KEVIN OF MILLION WITH THE
COALITION CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC I
HAVE BUT JUST NEEDED LIKE A
DUMB DUMB INSIDE THAT NO
WORRIES. PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY.
YOU HAVE. IF SUPPORTERS REPORT
A TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO- HI WITH
THE COURSE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
PROVIDE HER GRADUATION. WE'RE
PROBABLY TOP TWO SPONSOR THE
BILL WHEN. IT WOULD GRATEFUL
FOR THE OFF THE TOP OF THE
BILL- THIS WILL HELP- PEOPLE
WHO ARE CHAU WHO ON CAL WORKS
AND ALSO TRYING TO BECOME- TO-
TO OVERCOME POVERTY. BY GETTING
A JOB AND YOU START SOMETIMES
BUT OF SELF EMPLOYMENT
INSTRUMENTS SMALL AND YOU CAN'T
TURN A PROFIT RIGHT AWAY IT
TAKES AWHILE. EVEN THE PEOPLE
WORK FULL BOOK PART OF THE NEXT
LEVEL. THEY DON'T IF THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO MAKE MINIMUM WAGE
AND HOUR AND IF THEY DON'T
THAT. IN THIS IS JUST A
TECHNICAL THING MAKE SURE THAT
THE- HELLO. BACK FROM OPTION OF
HOW THEY- HOW THEY EMBARKED
UPON THE VOTE TO OVERCOME
POVERTY AND WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
OPERATOR DO WE. HAVE ANY PUBLIC
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. SORT
COMMENTS AND STUFF. OF AB. OR
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMANDED. WHY. ZERO WHEN
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. OR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB OR
SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH. THANK YOU
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE. NO FUTURE LIKE
TO CLOSE THIS REAL QUICK I
WOULD IT'S IMPORTANT AS A STATE
BEGINS TO RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WHO WANT TO
BECOME ENTREPRENEURS REALIZE
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN IRA. THANK
YOU SIR WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISSTATING FINISHED SECOND FOR
MR STONE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA.
CHOI GIPSON GIPSON ICE DOWN
STONE I AM REALLY PUT UP BY THE
PUT AYE MORE MORE HI IT IS SIX
TWO ZERO EIGHT THANK YOU OKAY
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT ON EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE. THAT'S. YEAH. NOT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT EIGHT NINE A BILL
REQUIRING A GROCERY STORE TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN NOTICE
UNDERSCORE WRITTEN NOTICE OF
ITS INTENT TO CLOSE A STORE- AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE- BUT NO LATER
THAN SIXTY DAYS OR A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DATES BECAUSE WE A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS DEPENDING
ON THE SIZE. OF THE STORE. THIS
MEASURE IS FOCUSED ON A BASIC
FAIRNESS MODEL. TO WORKERS AND
TO THE COMMUNITY THAT THAT
STORE IS LOCATED IN. THIS
NOTICE WILL PROVIDE TO THE CITY
AND THE COUNTIES WHERE STORE IS
LOCATED. THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
INVEST THE FULL WORK LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
AND- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. MEMBERS IF YOU
WERE EMPLOYED IF YOU WERE AN
EMPLOYEE AT RISK OF LOSING YOUR
JOB WOULD YOU WANT TO KNOW SOON
AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND LET ME JUST QUICKLY
SIMPLY SAY THIS. THAT IN A
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT THERE IS A
BEAUTIFUL LAST IN ANOTHER
DISTRICT MEMBERS DISTRICT
THERE'S A RALPH'S MARKET THAT
OF BOTH THE KROGER WHO OWNS
FOOD PLEASANT ROUGH MARKETS
DECIDE TO CLOSE THESE STORES.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
CITY IS DONE IN THOSE
PARTICULAR AREAS AND LOS
ANGELES AND THEY DECIDED TO
CLOSE THE STORES THIS BILL WILL
FOCUS TO SIMPLY SAY THAT YOU
KNOW YOU CLOSE ANY STORES.
THERE IT WOULD GIVE WRITTEN
NOTICE BETWEEN SIXTY AND A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS FOR THE
EMPLOYEES SO THAT THEY CAN ONE
RECEIVE- INFORMATION THAT THE
STORES CLOSING TO MAKE SURE
THAT RESOURCES ARE MADE
AVAILABLE. THREE MAKING SURE
THAT ALSO THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TRANSFER TO ANOTHER NEIGHBORING
STORE IF THAT COMPANY IN FACT
HAS A NEIGHBORING STORE CLOSE
BY. FOR MAKING SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY ALSO HAS MUCH NOTICE
AS NEEDED SO THAT THEY CAN ALSO
PIVOT AND MAKING SURE THEY CAN
FIND GROCERY. STORES THAT CAN
MEET THEIR PARTICULAR NEEDS IN
THIS PARTICULAR AREA ONCE FOOD
FOR LESS CLOSE THEY CLOSED LAST
WEEK. IT WILL LEAVE A COMEDIC A
COMPLETE FOOD DESERT- IN A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY- THAT IS-
UNDERSERVED AND HAVE A NUMBER
OF A FOOD DESERT- IN THAT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY AND THIS
IS OUR WAY UP TO ADDRESS TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE COMMUNITY
IS NOT DISENFRANCHISED ALSO THE
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
DISENFRANCHISED. AS A RESULT OF
A STORE CLOSING DURING A
PANDEMIC WE REALIZED THAT NOT
ONLY A HEALTHCARE INDIVIDUALS
ON THE FRONTLINE THE GROCERY
STORES WORKERS ON THE FRONT
LINE AS WELL AND TO DO THIS IN
THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC TO
THESE EMPLOYEES I THINK IS
WRONG. AND SO WE CAN'T STOP IT
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THOSE
BELLS AND WHISTLES AND PLACE TO
MAKING SURE THAT RESOURCES ARE
GIVEN TO EMPLOYEES. AND
OPPORTUNITIES BEEN TRANSFERRED
TO AVAILABLE- VACANCIES IN
SPOTS ARE ALSO BEING MADE AND
ALSO INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVING.
EBT IS ALSO MAKING SURE THEY
KNOW THEY NEIGHBORHOOD STORE IS
ALSO BE CLOSED AS WELL- TO I
HAVE TO TEST TO. IS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. AND I REPRESENT A
REPRESENTING U. S. C. W. WHO
ALL TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER GIPSON OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT. ALL
WITNESS LINES ARE CURRENTLY
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
PRESENTING THIS BILL THIS IS
ALBERTO TO RECALL THE UP THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS IN THERE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS I
DO WANNA GO SO A FEW OF THE
SECOND HALF OF THE PEOPLE
COMING TO MISTER GIBSON- FIRST
AND FOREMOST- THERE ARE TWO
MILLION. WHO DOES SOMETHING IN
OUR COUNTRY AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS
PLAGUED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
FOR DECADES AND I THINK THIS
THIS BILL IS A VERY VERY SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
DIRECTION OF TRYING TO CURTAIL-
DAY SPECIAL PUJAS WHICH RUN THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AS SOME
ASSEMBLY GIPSON MENTIONED. TWO
STORES RECENTLY WERE- COOK NOW
TO BE CLOSED BY KROGER'S IN THE
LONG BEACH AREA- THIS BILL
SIMPLY REQUIRES SIXTEEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS NOTICE FOR THE
WORKERS I THINK THAT SHOULD
MORE THAN FAIR I DO ALSO WANT
TO PUT SOME SOME ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT OVER THESE THE STORE
CLOSURES AND THE AUDACITY QUITE
FRONT OF THE STORE CLOSURES-
DURING THE CALL BUT CRISIS.
THERE HAVE BEEN RECORD SALES AT
GROCERY STORES AROUND THE
COUNTRY COKER'S AN ALBERTSON'S
OF SEEN SAUCE SALES IN THE LAST
YEAR- 10225% OVER THE PREVIOUS
YEAR- SECOND NOT ONLY OF
SILICON UP BUT PROFITS HAVE
GONE UP LET'S USE KROGER'S
AGAIN AS AN EXAMPLE THERE ARE
TWENTY NINETEEN PROFITS WERE
ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY DURING COVERT
THERE WERE TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION SO NOT ONLY ARE THERE
GETTING RECORD SALES. NOT ONLY
ARE THEY GETTING RECORD PROFITS
THEY ARE THEY PASSED TO THEM
POLICE TO COME TO WORK TO
RESTORE LIVES- TO PUT
THEMSELVES IT LITERALLY ON THE
FRONTLINE- IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE
TO CONTINUE TO EAT AND IT'S AND
IT'S SO UNFAIR NO IN RESPONSE
TO ALL OF THAT SACRIFICE FOR
THE GROCERY STORES NOW TO SAY.
WE DON'T WANT TO PAY A HUNDRED
PLAYED A FULL INSTALL CLOSING
GROCERY STORES IT IT'S REALLY
IT'S MIND BOGGLING AND
APPALLING THAT THEY WOULD DO
THAT AND FOR THOSE REASONS THE
UNITED FOR A COMMERCIAL WORKERS
AS FOR NAY VOTE ON. A. B. EIGHT
EIGHT NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. CHAIRMAN OKAY LET HIM.
WITH THE COALITION TELL WHAT'S
RIGHTS ARE WITH. TO BISP. OF
THIS WONDERFUL. AND BASICALLY
THE PRIMARY THAT WE SPONSOR
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE WE
REPRESENT CHAO WORKS USE. THANK
CHAO WILL SWITCH BIDS BUT UP BY
PERCENT OF LEAVES DON'T EVEN
HAVE A CAR. AND THEY BASICALLY
GO TO THE STORE ONCE A WEEK TO
FIND FOOD PATTERSON DO TRICIA
AND AFFORDABLE AND THEN WE TOOK
THE STORE CLOSES AND IF THEY
GET THERE WEEKLY RISE GOLD
THERE FIND OUT THE STORES
CLOSED W. HORRIBLE SO WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE GET
A NOTICE. THAT THE STORES WILL
BE CLOSED THEN AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEWORK IS ALSO OVER THE
HAVE THE PROPER INFORMATION SO
THEY WANT TO END UP IN POVERTY
FOR THESE REASONS WHICH LONGER
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE URGE
AND I BOUGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. I TO WE HAVE ANY. A
PUBLIC THE ON THE- FOR AND OF
AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY. YEP LIMóN
CHEN NUMBER OF CUSTOMER
SANCTIONS POLITECNICA WESTERN
PLAN ON PROPERTY THE PUBLIC
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO OTHER COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM- OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL WITNESS LINES
ARE OPEN. HI- WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION. OKAY HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD. OKAY I KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IS OPPOSED TO EIGHTY EIGHTY
NINE AS IT'S CURRENTLY DRAFTED-
WE WILL LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICER BEING OPEN TO
WORKING WITH US AND HELP YOU
GET YOUR CONSENT CONSENSUS ON
THE BILL AFTER THE BILL IMPRINT
IS OPPOSED TO THE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DAY NOTICE OR SIX
MONTH NOTICE OF EACH ARE
CLOSER- EMPLOYERS ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER THE FEDERAL IN
CALIFORNIA WARN ACT TO NOTIFY
THE EMPLOYEES EDT LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABOUT THE
CLOSURE. EMPLOYERS ARE ALSO
SUBJECT TO PENALTIES IF. THEY
DO NOT COMPLY WITH EXISTING LAW.
I THE FEDERAL LAW OUT AND WITH
A HIGH OR MORE COME IN. IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE DECOR
GOVERNOR- UNDER THE CAL. WAR
ACT AN EMPLOYER WITH THEM FIVE
OR MORE FOR EMPLOYEES IS
REQUIRED PROVIDE A- DAY CLOSE.
IT WILL ALSO HELP YOU. THE IN
OF. COMPETITION ENTRY UP TOOK.
THAT COULD FORCE THE CLOSED.
SECOND UP RECORD BEING A
HUNDRED THE AND HOW EIGHTY IN
ADVANCE. SO THAT HAVE BEEN
UNDERPERFORMING. CERTAINLY GET
WITH A LARGE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS CANNOT COMPLY WITH THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY NOTED AND
CANNOT FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE.
FOR THE SIX MONTHS. FORTY THREE
THEN- WE OPPOSE AB IN EIGHT
NINE AND IT'S CURRENTLY.
DRAFTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
ONLINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO I COMMEND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE THANK YOU.
AND I'LL JUST BE ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
IN LINE FIVE HUNDRED SIX YOUR
MY GET UP. HI THIS IS RYAN-
LAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND THIS TO WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON FOR I'M
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION I
UNDERSTAND AND- AND FULLY
SYMPATHIZE WITH THAT THE NEED
FOR THE BILL I'M LEARNING IF
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHY YOU CHOSE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DAYS AND- IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE YOU ARE
WORKING ON IT JUST FEELS. LONG
VERY DIFFICULT TO PREDICT WHAT
MARKET CONDITIONS MIGHT LOOK
LIKE FIVE MONTHS FROM NOW TO
MAKE THAT DECISION OF WHAT
HAPPENED SIX MONTHS FROM NOW
AND IF THERE'S ALREADY EXISTING
LAW THAT-YOU KNOW MANDATE
CERTAIN THINGS HAPPEN WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OR SEVENTY FIVE
DAYS- ARE ARE YOU WORKING ON ON
A TIME PERIOD THAT MIGHT-
IMPLEMENT WELL. I AM CERTAINLY
WILL IS- WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
FIRST- SECONDLY HOW CARE IF THE
STORES GETTING READY TO CLOSE
RIGHT WE SHOULD HAVE A THERE
SHOULD BE NO OBLIGATION.
ESPECIALLY TO FRONTLINE WORKERS
TO GIVE THEM AS MUCH AS NOTICED
AS POSSIBLE I DON'T THINK SIX
MONTHS NOTICE IF THEY KNOW- BUT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT NOTICE THIS
IS NOT ABOUT DAYS IS ABOUT WHAT
A CD JOHNSON TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE TO MAKE SURE THOSE FRONT
LINE WORKERS. WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING DAY IN DAY OUTJUST
LIKE ARE HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
IS THE OVER DISPUTE OVER THE
HERO MONEY THAT CITIES PASS TO
SUPPORT GROWTH STORE WORKERS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
NOT THE GOD IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THAT IS ABOUT WHAT THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND THE CITY. OF
LONG BEACH DID THAT BROUGHT US
INTO THIS THAT I HAVE I DON'T
BEGRUDGE THEM I THINK WE SHOULD
BE PAYING THESE GROCERY STORE
WORKERS BUT TO UP IN CLOSE
INCOME IN A COMMUNITY THAT'S
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET I THINK IT'S NOT TOO MUCH
TO ASK FOR THEM TO GIVE THEM A
SIX MONTH DEPLOYMENT SIXTY
DAYS. TO HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
WITHOUT A NOTICE. RIGHT AND I
AGREE WITH YOU ESPECIALLY I
THINK THAT THE OPERATIVE PHRASE
THEY IS IF. KNOW AND THE NOT
YOU KNOW TO THE THAT THE CAN IS
ARE SO TINY. TO SOME IS GONNA
CHANGE REVENUE LIKE CERTAINLY
POINT THEY HAVEN'T- PEOPLE ARE
USING THE GROCERY STORE BUT IF.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING REALLY
CHANGES A CIRCUMSTANCES- WITHIN
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY MAY
FEEL THE NEED TO FIGURE THAT
OUT AS A BUSINESS SITE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT PERSPECTIVE TO
AND YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION- FOR
EXAMPLE CONSOLES THIS BILL FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT. YOU
KNOW I HAD A NINETY DAY
TRANSITION PERIOD TO MAKE SURE
THAT EMPLOYEES COULD TRANSFER
FROM ONE- ONE ONE PLAY TO A
SUCCESSOR EMPLOYER- AND SO JUST
I THINK I LOVE THE- GIVEN A
COURTESY I TODAY- BUT JUST KIND
OF CONTINUE TO. TIE ALL THESE
TOGETHER INTO TIME FRAMES THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR BOTH PARTIES- I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENT AND
I. I CONCUR AGAIN I WILL WE
WILL WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION-
TO. FIND A MIDDLE GROUND- BUT I
DON'T THINK WE CAN GIVE THOSE
EMPLOYEES- ANOTHER HEADS UP
NOTICE. AND I THINK AGAIN WE
CAN'T STOP THIS DOOR FROM
CLOSING OR NONE OF THE STORES
FROM CLOSING. BUT WE SHOULD
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
OBLIGATION TO THOSE EMPLOYEES
TO MAKING SURE. THAT ONE TAKE
PREPARE THEMSELVES SOMETIME IT
TAKES A LOOK AT MORE. THAN US
SIX WEEKS OR OR SIXTY DAYS IN
ORDER TO PREPARE YOURSELF
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
LOSING YOUR JOB. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A TOOL WE KNOW WHEN WE
KNOW OUR EXPIRATION DATE HERE'S
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATURE. SO WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE END OF OUR TERM.
THESE EMPLOYEES DOESN'T HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF THAT AND ALL I'M
SAYING IS THAT DURING THIS
TIME- EXPENSE YOU DOING A
PANDEMIC- THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN. WE SHOULD GIVE
THEM AS MUCH TIME AS MUCH
NOTICE. AS MUCH RESOURCES AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. THANK YOU MAY
DAVIS. THANK MISTER GIPSON. A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND- SOMETHING
LIKE A GROCERY STORE WHICH
COULD BE A PRIVATE- BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE AT WILL
WORKERS THERE AS WELL. AND SO
DID GIVING SOMEONE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS- YOU COULD HAVE
EVER DECIDE TO LEAVE. AND ALSO
YOU HAVE NOBODY THERE TO BE
EMPLOYED. I THINK FOR ME BY
QUESTION IS IF YOU WITH THIS
ONE FORWARD- WHAT TYPE FIND
WHAT IT BE AND IF THIS PLACE IS
GOING UNDER. YOU KNOW HOW ARE
THEY SUPPOSED TO PAY IT- YOU
SAID ABOUT BY TO FIND. YOU HAVE
THAT YOU HAVE A BANDAID THAT
THEY HAVE TO GET DISCONNECTED
WHAT WOULD BE THE REPLICATIONS
OF IF THEY'RE NOT DOING THIS
WHAT WAS THAT AGAIN WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON ON THE BILL IN THE
LANGUAGE- AND SO THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
CERTAINLY GOING TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WORK
OUT SOMETHING IS REASONABLE
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING FOR ME M.
M. FROM MY LAND IS MAKING SURE
THAT EMPLOYEES- THIS WOULD NOT
BE. A MOM AND POP BUSINESS
BECAUSE THE TALK ABOUT SQUARE
FOOT AS WE TALK ABOUT- WE DO
LOOK AT TRADER JOE'S TEN
THOUSAND SQUARE IF WE LOOK AT-
SUPER WALLMARK A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A HUGE DIP-
GROCERY STORE SO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A MOM AND POP
GROCERY STORE WE TALK ABOUT A
CHAIN- SPECIALLY IN THIS CASE
IS THE NATIONAL CHAIN KROGER
THAT OWNS FOOD LASSEN ALSO
WRAPS MARKETS. IT AND I
UNDERSTAND BELIEVE A GIRL SHE'S
THE DEFINITION GROCERY STORES
LIKE FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET-
AND- SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR REALLY IS WHAT WHAT
IS THE PENALTY YOU KNOW WHAT IT
IS IT REALISTIC IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S SO HIGH
THEY'RE GOING UNDER IT AND THEY
DON'T YOU KNOW IT WAS GOOD PAID
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR SURE AND I WOULD JUST IN
RESPONSE TO THAT- ONE THAT-
BECAUSE ALBERTA TO RICO TALKED
ABOUT- THE AMOUNT OF PROFIT
THAT. THEY MADE LAST YEAR OVER
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS- AND
YOU KNOW SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT A GREAT A COMPANY WHO
WILL GO UNDER- IT WEATHERS WE
RESPECT TO THIS WE TALK ABOUT
COMPANY HAS MADE MONEY HAND
OVER FIST AGAIN I THINK ABOUT
THE EMPLOYEES WHEN. CRAFTING
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION. YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW SOME REMEMBER
GIPSON- I- APOLOGIZE I IF FOR
THIS QUESTION HAS ARISEN
ALREADY- BUT- I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT SO WHY. YOU ARE- GROCERY
STORES ON THE- WHERE IS- ANY-
THOUGH- BUSINESSES ARE CLOSING-
WILL HAVE A EMPLOYEES AT AND
THEN NOT WITH A CERTAIN NUMBER
ONE EMPLOYEES SO WITHOUT. LACK
A FEDERAL WARRANT ACT HAS SOME
MORE THAN A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
TO AND I'M NOT- CAL CALIFORNIA
WARN ACT TO- SPECIFIES- SEVENTY
FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES FOR TERM
IMPROPER USE OF TO NOTIFY- THE-
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THOUGH AND- IS
ALREADY EXISTING LAW AND OF
BEING PRACTICED SO I RECEIVED
THOSE SUCH A NOTICES SO WHEN I
WAS SO- WITH THE- A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- BUT THE. Y. HI IS
IT THE- DIFFERENT FROM THAT THE
WAR- TAX THAT SAW EXISTS- I
HADN'T. THE. THE NOTICE OF PURE
UNIT OF TWO HOURS OF FEDERAL
HIS SISTER DAY OF GROW OR IS
AND THE ROLE CAN WARRANT SUBS
SIXTY OF NO A BUT THE- WHETHER
YOU ARE CHANGE- THE- THE PERIOD
THE WHOLE MANY DAYS IN ADVANCE
OF THE COURTS ARE STORED SO
WOULD HAVE TO- NOTIFY THIS IS A.
ONE EXAMPLE ONE. REGULATE AFTER
ANOTHER- YOU MAY KNOW THAT THE-
I THINK THAT'S A SUITABLE BEACH
A RECENTLY CLOSED- TO- GROCERY
CHAINS OWNED BY KROGER
ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE OF- HERE
WILL PAY REQUIREMENTS- THAT WAS
SO AND OF THE BURDEN. YOU KNOW
EVEN SO INTENT THE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN GOOD BUT- THAT KIND OF A
REQUIREMENT IS SO LITERALLY
KILLING THE BUSINESSES. AND YOU
CAN THINK ABOUT. WHAT KIND OF
LOST A JOB LOSS AND THE REVENUE
LOSS FOR THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
ETCETERA THIS IS A AND I DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW HOW AWFUL TO ME.
ON NECESSARY BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY PRE EXISTING AND KNOW
WHAT THIS- LAW WOULD REQUIRE
WHAT WHAT WHAT BENEFITS TO WILL
BRING. US TO THE EMPLOYEES. OR
TO THE COMMUNITY. SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN CALL ON THE
SURE AND WE DID COVER SOME OF
THAT THAT YOU JUST SPOKE OF
ONE. IT PROVIDES A COMMUNITY
NOTICE- ON THE DOOR OF THE
STORE THIS BEING CLOSE TO IT
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO WORKS THERE TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR SELVES IN
ORDER TO SPECIALLY KNOWING.
THAT THEY WILL NO LONGER HAVE A
JOB BECAUSE THE STORE BEING
CLOSED AND WE BELIEVE SIXTY
SIXTY FOUR- A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS IS GIVING THOSE EMPLOYEES
AND UP ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY. SO
THAT THEY CAN ALSO ADDRESS
THEIR PERSONAL SITUATION
BECAUSE THEY LOSING INCOME BUT
ALSO PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO TRANSFER TO OTHER
STORES IF IN FACT THERE'S
VACANCIES IN THOSE OTHER STORES
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH INSIDE OF LOS
ANGELES. INTO RICK REGARDING TO
THE THIS HERO PAY- THOSE
EMPLOYEES CAN NOT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT THOSE
EMPLOYEES ARE CAUGHT UP IN THE
IN THE WINDMILL- AND TERMS OF
THE RESULTS THAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE AS SOON AS THOSE
CITIES. PASSED THE HERO- ACT%
THAT'S WHEN THEY MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT- I WOULD VENTURE
TO SAY THAT NOW SO WE COULD
HAVE CAME AT A AT A FUNNY TIME-
WOULD THEY HAVE ANNOUNCED THESE
STORE CLOSURES IF IN FACT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES CITY OF
LONG BEACH. HAD NOT ASKING
PUSHED FOR AND WON IN THE COURT
SAYING THAT IT'S PERMISSIBLE TO
ASK THESE GROCERY STORES TO-
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR
THESE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
IS IT UNREASONABLE FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO STEP UP TO WE TALK
ABOUT A NOTICE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A NOTICE TO PROVIDE TO
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE TO SHIFT
THEIR LIVES WHO HAVE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR THEIR LIVES THE
NOTICE IS NOT GOING TO STOP THE
STORE FROM CLOSING. AND THAT'S
THE UNDERLYING THIS THE NOTICE
TO MAKING SURE THEY HAVE
RESOURCES TO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD THOSE WHO
RECEIVE EDT BENEFITS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED
THAT THE NEIGHBORHOOD STORE
THEIR CUSTOM TO GOING TO WILL
NO LONGER BE THERE. FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHEELCHAIRS TAKING
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO KNOW
THAT STORE WILL BE CLOSED BOTH
OF THOSE DOORS YOU MAKE.
MENTION OF LONG BEACH IN LONG
BEACH THE FOOD LESS THAN A-
MARC. TODAY JUST BECAUSE I
THINK THEY CLOSED. LET WEEK SO.
WHO ARE TO PUBLIC. HAS NOW
PIVOT. TO MAKING SURE THEY CAN
FIND GROCERY NEED SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
NOTICE. WE CAN'T STOP THE STORE
FROM CLOSING BUT WE SHOULD HAVE
A OBLIGATION AND A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO NOTIFY THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THOSE
EMPLOYEES HAVE THE RESOURCES
MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM. SO THAT
THEY COULD ALSO LOOK FOR
EMPLOYMENT. ELSEWHERE HE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT THE FEDERAL. THE
FEDERAL LAW WHICH IS GOING A
STEP FURTHER BY ASKING FOR THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. BECAUSE WE
DON'T THINK THAT'S ENOUGH TIME.
AND BEFORE I GOT HERE I SAID
THAT I WOULD CERTAINLY WORK
WITH OF THE OPPOSITION TO COME
TO MIDDLE GROUND. THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY ANSWER MY QUESTIONS-
THEY WERE KIND OF THE SAME
QUESTIONS ARE POSED BY MISTER
WATER- MISS DAVIES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO-
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
ON THIS MEASURE AN- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION
YEAH. SECOND SECOND OKAY. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON I CALLED RUN
HIDE DAVIES DAVIES NARROW
ARAMBULA. CHOI SO I KNOW GIPSON
FIVE GIPSON AYE STONE. STONE HI
VILAKKU THAT WILL PUT UP I LORD
LORD HI THE VOTED. FIVE TO TWO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT UP
NEXT WE HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
HOLDEN WHICH WE PRESENTING FOR
SUMMER HOLDEN. EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
SEVEN. THE BILL. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ALREADY HAVE THIS OF
THE SOMEONE HOLDEN SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN. THIS BILL WILL GIVE US
THE TOOLS TO EVALUATE THE
LICENSING AND CRIMINAL
EXEMPTION PROCESS THE BILL
CALLS ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO BEGIN
COLLECTING DATA FROM CLEARANCE
AN EXEMPTION APPLICATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY DEMOGRAPHICS ON
AGE ETHNICITY GENDER AND
CONVICTED CRIMES FROM
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE DENIED
CLEARANCE AND EXEMPTIONS.
CURRENTLY THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT COLLECTED FROM APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE DENIED OR GRANTED
CLEARANCES OR EXEMPTIONS WHICH
IS A GREAT DISSERVICE TO THE
FACILITIES AND LEGAL CENTERS A
FIGHT EVERY DAY FOR THESE
APPLICANTS RIGHT TO WORK. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP THAT WILL EVALUATE THE
CURRENT CURRENT CRIMINAL
EXEMPTION PROCESS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY. WHEN WE GET
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE WE WILL
BE ABLE TO MAKE THE REAL CHANGE
THAT ADDRESSES THE ISSUES THE
DATA WILL SHOW. LASTLY THE BILL
PROHIBITS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FROM REQUIRING
A PERSON TO DESCRIBE THEIR OWN
CONVICTIONS. ON THE INITIAL
APPLICATION AND THEREFORE
CREATING A CANTOR TRAP. DSS
MUST RELY ON THE MORE ACCURATE
DOJ AND FBI RECORDS TO EVALUATE
AN APPLICANT. RATHER THAN THE
APPLICANT'S MEMORY THESE ARE
THE SAME RECORDS THAT I HSS.
AIRPORTS AND MANY OTHER STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES RELY ON
FOR HIRING. THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS STUDY IT'S A CHANGE
WE KNOW WE NEED RIGHT NOW. FOR
THESE REASONS. GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY. FOR THESE REASONS- I'D
LIKE. TO OKAY SORRY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL OR JAIL
MYRICK OF THE EAST BAY
LAWCENTER AND J. SMITH. WHO HAS
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH
ISSUE. Q. OPERATOR FOR THE
FIRST WITNESS. YES THEY ARE
MYRICK FROM THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CONNECT EVERYBODY
EVERY YES THANK YOU- I'M
ASSUMING GREAT- SO THANK YOU
CHAIR CALL FOR ON BILL I'M WANT
TO GIVE ALL QUICK NUMBER SIX
THOUSAND THREE AND THIRTY THREE
THAT THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE AND I
MONTH PERIOD THAT LOCKED ARMS.
DO THE ONE THE PRIME NOT
BECAUSE THEY FOUND TO BE
ADDRESS CURRENT WERE FOUND BE
WERE NOT BECAUSE OF THE PROPER
BUT THE LENT A THE PROCESS OF
NOW TIME TO PAY TOOK LETTER THE
MOVING THE JOB ALL. LEFT IN
EIGHT PEOPLE THAT THE OF PEOPLE
THAT TIME PERIOD TIME THAT
ACTUALLY WERE DENIED ON WHAT ON
THEIR RECORD- SO AGAIN SIX
THOUSAND LOST THEIR BECAUSE IT
COOKS LONG ONLY LET EIGHT
HUNDRED ACTUALLY GONNA BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S ON THE RECORD- AND
THEN THE NEXT MILITARY ALL
AROUND THE DAY USE THAT THE
ABOUT OF TIME TO TAKES FOR
SOMEONE TO GO THROUGH EXEMPTION
FOR. INTERVIEW LETTERS- YOU
KNOW YOU HIGHER PEOPLE FOR
STAFF IMAGINE IF YOU HIRED
SOMEONE FOR A ON YOUR STAFF AND
AFTER HIRING THEM YOU. THAT YOU
HAVE TO WAIT ONE DAYS THE
PUBLIC START TO PROBABLY NOT
GONNA BE TO KEEP PERSON BECAUSE
OF GONNA NEED TO HIRE SOME ELSE
TAX DO THAT WERE IN THE
MEANTIME- IN THE LAST NUMBER OF
THIS YEAR 50% THAT A NUMBER WE
THAT ARE GONNA BE BECOME LOCKED
IN A- BE A PERCENTAGE THE
PEOPLE THROUGH THE BIG IMPROPER-
HAVING TO GO THROUGH. WHAT IS
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE WANT
TO OF THE DATA AND ITSELF SO I
HOPE THAT YOU ALL WILL MOVE
FORWARD WE'RE HOPEFUL AT THE
SHER SAID THAT BY GETTING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER WITH THESE
WORKING GROUPS WE CAN ACTUALLY
COME TO A CONCLUSION AND A
DECISION THAT EVERYBODY CAN BE
COMFORTABLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LIVING I TURN NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER SMITH- HELLO EVERYONE
YES THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING I.
MONDAY OKAY DATE- GAVE I'M WHAT
BUT THE OF BECAUSE I FELT. NOT
THAT. I THAT'S FINE FOR EIGHT
AND WE. SEVEN ELIMINATING QUITE.
ABOUT IT AT THAT THEY RELY ON
IN YOUR FAVORITE. TODAY AM ONLY
THAT NOT I THINK ARE AS HE
LEADS THE ARE LOOKING. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PEOPLE ARE IN
ANIMALS. WE MY MOTHER I DON'T
THINK THAT BECAME PRIMARY CARE
AN ADVOCATE. FOR- THANK YOU-
THEN IT I THOUGHT- EFFORT TO
DEFEAT. I'VE HEARD THE PAST. A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL VICTIMS
THEY- THANK YOU WHAT WE KNOW. I
WANTED TO WEAR HERE FEEL BY CAN
HELP HEAL PATIENTS THEIR FELLOW
I'LL FIND THEM HERE. I'M
PULLING AT DIDN'T OKAY. EVELYN
WELL NO THANK YOU FOR YES THIS
IS ONE. THE AT IS VERY EARLY
RESPONSIBILITY EARLY ON I DID I
DIDN'T THE SAFETY WITH THEIR-
BUT IF THE ENTIRE DON'T THINK
HE I HAVE THE IMPACT. YEAH I
HAD. THAT WOULD NEED A KNOW HOW
I DO KNOW I HAD AT THE KNOW I
WOULD BE I WOULD NOT DIG DEEP
AT AT THE HE THE CASF SOUNDS A
LOT TO HELP WITH. DESPITE MY OF
THE BILL WILL GET THE EVERY.
LETTER TO. THANK FOR HELP AND
I'M LOOK. BUT ABOUT MY. THREE
IT BUT AFTER EIGHTY ABOUT THE
LIVE OFF THE PAPERWORK. EIGHT
SEVEN. THE BATTERY ONLY. FOR
CONCRETE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
MY BEGAN TO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
I'M NOT SEEING ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WILL MOVE DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
THE R. T. S. ROOMS. K. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LIVE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
SEVEN. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
MORE COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS.
IN THAT LINE OF FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS PRESS ON IT OFF BEHALF
THE CENTRE FOREIGN PLAN
OPPORTUNITIES SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU. LINE TO HER SIXTY
NINE YOUR MY KIDS UP. JENNIFER
NINETEEN LEGAL IN EAST PALO AND-
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS IS AB FROM
THE WOMEN'S LAW- CALLING
SUPPORT THE BILL. IN LINE OF
FIVE TWENTY OR MY COULD OPEN.
MY WATER. SEE WHAT THEN I'LL
MAKE COUNTY PA DEFENDER'S CREE
SLATE IN STRONG AT EIGHTY AT
SIX SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FOR COMMENT THAT
THE TIME THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES NOT THIS. ALL
RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY ANY
SUPPORT IN THE SORRY DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION- IN THE R. T. S.
ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE. RIGHT OPERATOR
ANY OPPOSITION. OR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT AP SIX SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN.
ZERO I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. IS MR
TRUMP H. CHAIR- HOW MANY HAPPY
TO VOTE NO ON THE- TO MAKE JUST
A- I IT THROUGH THE- ESSENTIAL
THIS IS OVER- TO MAKE. CREATION
WORKING GROUP AS SUCH BOTTOM
LINE IN- ANY APPLICANT THE TWO
K. FOR SAID INCLUDE- EDITOR
REST CARE LAW CHARLIE FACILITY.
THE NOT TO. DISCLOSE THAT THERE
OF CRIMINAL BACK. THIS A VERY
TO ALSO VULNERABLE PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO BE PART- I'M IN I CAN I
THE WHOLE ANY JOB- THROUGH THE
PROCESS- TO OKAY- AND OF THE
CHANCE FOR THOSE OF MY THE HERE
IS A APPLE ARE TO CARE FOR SAN.
FOR HANDLING WATCH TALK. WELL
ALL MORE FOR. AND THAT THIS OF-
SHE SHOULDN'T JUST CLOSE THE
ECONOMY ON THAT FOR THIS IS A
VERY TRUMP TO ME THAT'S THE
REASON I WILL BE VOTING FOR IT
MIGHT IF I MAY JUST RE SIR THE
FIVE CARE HAS OF THIRD. APPLE
PROCESS THE FOSTER PARENTS MUST
GO THROUGH TO A FASTER YOU ARE
PLACED A SECURE IN THIS BILL.
IT'S SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE WHO
BE AND TO WORK X. FOR NOT THE-
GUARD. OF A CHILD- AND IT'S- I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT ADDRESSES CA
ARE THAT TO. IT'S JUST NOT ALSO
PROGRAM. ACTUALLY DEFER THAT TO
THE WITNESS TO OF THE WOMEN ON
THE- IT'S- IT YES THOSE ARE
REAL THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
ABOUT IS HIGHLY. IT'S NOT PILOT
PROGRAM I THINK THE CHAIR
POINTING IS THAT- AND I THINK
IT VERY. YES WILL STILL GIVE
DOT RACKS ON EVERY. TOLD DFS
WILL STILL GET THE RAP SHEET
THE STILL HAVE THE ACT TO THE
TO GET THAT. TO LOOK TO SEE
WHAT TALK ABOUT RECORD THE
QUESTION IS ALL WHETHER NOT THE
PERSON AT THE CELL DISCLOSE ON
THE FRONT END MOST PEOPLE DO
NOT UNDER WHAT IS WRONG
CRIMINAL. THIS JUSTICE THAT'S
JUST HOW YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
TO. IN REAL UNDERSTAND CRIMINAL
LAW A LOT OF PEOPLE NOT UNDER.
WHAT IS ON THE RECORD SO THE
ONLY THING WE'RE- IS OF HAVING
TO PERSON'S DISCLOSED. YES
APPLE BE A TO MAKE THAT THE
BASED ON THEY SEE ON SOME OF
OUR THE OTHER APPS AND IT'LL
HAVE THE WORKING GROUP TO
DETERMINE HOW TO DEAL GOING
FORWARD THE BROADER. EXEMPTION
PROCESS. CHOI CHOI NO GIPSON
GIPSON ICE STONE THE LEVEL. AT
THE LAGUNA II WARD WARD HI THE
LOTUS FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAULDRON OF
PLEASE OPEN UP ON AB ONE THREE
SIX EIGHT. SECOND I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SEEKS TO ESTABLISH THE
ENHANCED SERVICES PROGRAM FOR A
SAILLY OR IS HE S. P. A. FOR
SHORT WITHIN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
INDIVIDUALS GRANTED ASYLUM HAVE
LEGAL PROTECTION STATUS IS DUE
TO THE THREAT OF PERSECUTION
BASED ON THEIR RACE OR
RELIGION. THE FAMILIES DIFFER
FROM REFUGEES AS THEY START
SEEKING PROTECTION UPON ARRIVAL
TO THE UNITED STATES WELL
REFUGEES SEEK HELP WHILE
THEY'RE STILL IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRY UPON ARRIVING TO THE U.
S. REFUGEES- ASSIGNED A CASE
WORKER TO HELP CONNECT THEM
WITH THE SOCIAL SERVICES THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR. THIS INITIAL-CONNECTION WITH THE CASE WORKER
IS NOT MADE FOR A SITE LEASE
RESULTING IN MOST SOCIETIES
HAVING TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLICATED SOCIAL SERVICES
SYSTEMS ALONE THE CREATION OF
THE S. P. A. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WILL MIRROR WHAT IS
OFFERED TO REFUGEES FORCE I
LEASE THE S. P. A. WILL PROVIDE
A SITE LEASE WITH CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR UP TO NINETY DAYS
AND WITH IT ACCESS TO ALL THE
BENEFITS AND WHICH THEIR LIFE
LAWFULLY ENTITLED TO. HERE WITH
ME TODAY IS POLYMER ALICE FROM
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND RENEE TOM
BANG. WHO IS AND IF I LEAVE
FROM CAMERON. THANK YOU WE
COULD EVER FIRST WITNESS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME- COUPLE IN WHAT I LIST I
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA A SIDEWAYS AND
UPSIDE THE CHILDREN. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MADAM CHAIR LISA CALDERON FOR
OFFERING AND INTRODUCED IN THIS
VITAL AND IMPORTANT BILL IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND FOR HER UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY. AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA WALKING COALITION A
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP BRING
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
POLITE THANK WOULD WEAR ALL
AMERICA INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS CALIFORNIA
HIGHEST INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF L. A. INTERFAITH REFUGEE AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES IRIS ON
REFUGEES AND OXFAM AMERICA. AN
ASYLUM SEEKER- AS I DON'T THINK
THERE'S. PRESENT THEIR CASE AND
IN SOME INSTANCES BUT. ON THE.
THERE. WITHIN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO BE AFFECT I PROGRAM WHAT
WHAT CASE MANAGEMENT FOR FOUR
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS GROW A IN
CALIFORNIA ENSURING THEY
RECEIVE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND RESPONSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
FOR UP TO NINETY DAYS IF IDEAS
MODELED AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT MODEL
CONNECTING REFUGEES WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES HAVE PROVED TO BE
ESSENTIAL TO THEIR ACHIEVING
SELF SUFFICIENCY. WE NEED TO
ENSURE OUR FAMILIES ARE ALL
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FLAG CHANGING
SERVICE. BALANCE FIGURES ONE
THE WRECKAGE. CALIFORNIA
COMPLAIN ROLE IN LEADING THE
NATION ONCE AGAIN BY BEING
PROACTIVE AND INTENTIONAL IN
PROVIDING AND INCLUSIVE
APPROACH TO A FIVE EIGHT I
PASSING AB THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WE CAN HELP OF FAMILIES
NAVIGATE OUR COMPLEX SYSTEMS
ENSURE THEY START OFF AND STAY
STRONG IN ORDER TO BUILD A
SOLID FOUNDATION FOR THEY TOO
ARE THE FUTURE CALIFORNIA.
ANCHOR YOU TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY
SIXTY EIGHT TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. WE HAVE A WHEN
PLACED. RENAY JUMPING. AND
THAT'S IT YEAH. BOB GRAHAM A
FIVE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS THE
OPERATOR DO NOT SHOW THE RENDON
HAD. A WHITE THERE SHE IS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISS CHAMPAK.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. SOMEBODY'S
STILL TALKING NOW WE'RE WE CAN
HEAR YOU SO PLEASE GO AHEAD-
OKAY THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RENEE CHARMING I'M
FROM CAMEROON. BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL PERSECUTION I WAS
FORCED TO FLEE FROM MY COUNTRY
I'M SICK. REFUGIUM PROTECTION
IN THE UNITED STATES. IN
ADDITION TO THE TRAUMA I STATES
IN THE COUNTRY IT JENNY COMING
TO AMERICA WAS VERY TRAUMATIC.
WHEN I ARRIVE I DO NOT HAVE
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
COULD GO TO AND ASK FOR HELP.
MY FEDERAL CASE TOOK ABOUT
THREE AND A HALF YEARS TO BE
PROCESS. I'M DURING ALL THAT
TIME I WAS THE GREAT THAT FOR
MY HUSBAND AND CHILDREN. SO
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS.
THE LONG WAIT MEN MAY FEEL
DEPRESSED. ON ONE LAST SILENCE
I PROVE I KNEW THAT THERE WAS A
NEW BEGINNING I HOPE FOR ME AND
MY FAMILY. BUT I HAVE A FEELING.
THAT FEELING OF HOPE CAN BE
LOVE WHERE DO NOT KNOW WHERE TO
GO WHAT BENEFITS YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO. THERE IS A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION. I'M HERE. OF
ASKING FOR HELP I'M HERE TODAY
I FROM MY SIDE LEAD I'M UP IN
THE AMERICAN TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT NO MATTER HOW I SAY LEASE
GET HERE. I THANK THESE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE.
I THANK LIVE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME BENEFITS OF SEAFOOD
CHEESE. THERE SHOULD BE NO
DISTINCTION. WE NEED SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
REFUGEES. BECAUSE I JUST HAPPEN
TO HAVE. MY FAMILY JOIN ME AND
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IT WAS NOT
EASY WE CERTAINLY MY FAMILY
HERE. SO I THINK THAT WE ALSO
DO NEED SUPPORT BECAUSE AFTER
ALL WE ARE ALSO IN A NEW
COUNTRY I'M STRUGGLING TO SAID
SO. I THEIR FULL SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL. I KNOW
WE WANT TO CREATE. THAT THIS
BILL BE PASSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. ALL RIGHT DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SUPPORT ON PHONE LINES. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE.
FIVE HUNDRED FOURTEEN. GOVERNOR
MANAGER MEMBERS COACH FOR
SPONSORED POLICY OF YOUR
BLISTERS ON A MOM PROBABLY WENT
SUPPORT. AND OUTLINES FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL AND CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
OF ANY AGO WHERE AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MIKE IT'S
UP. I THE JOKE BOTH MEN
REPRESENTING HIGH IT'S THE
WORLD'S OLDEST ALL THE JEWISH
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT AGENCY
WORKING OF WITH OVER SEVENTY
CONGREGATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND OTHER SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES HERE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LINE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX YEAR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MARKETS AUG
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES OFFICE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
A GLOBAL HUMANITARIAN
ORGANIZATION. ON BEHALF OF I.
R. C. AND THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE
WORLD I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THANKS.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE HUNDRED
ELEVEN YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
THANK YOU AMBER SHE WITH CARE
CALIFORNIA LARGE. ORGANIZATION
IN THE NATION STRONG WORD OF
THE THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A
COUPLE MORE COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE HOLD
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE
NUMBERS. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YOUR MIKE AT THE. I
FEEL GOOD GOING BECAUSE YOUR
COW ONE NOT BE EIGHT YOU CAN
HELP US- WITH IT AB. APROPOS
FRIEDMAN. TO PUT THE TICKET.
THANK YOU. AND A LINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED NINETEEN YEAR MIKE AT
THE. ANAHITA CANNOT HE WITH THE
WE ARE ALL AMERICA CAMPAIGN
AMBER CALIFORNIA WELCOMED
COALITION AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YU I DON'T SEE ANY- A
PUBLIC SUPPORTING HEARING ROOMS
WILL GO LIVE TO THEM- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. OR DO WE HAVE ANY-
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION AP
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGHAT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SINGLE I'M A POSITION HEARING
ROOM- DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE MR WARD THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF WORK AND I'M
REALLY I'M THANKFUL THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON THIS HERE SO THANK
YOU FOR- PUSHING THIS BILL.
WHAT OKAY ALL RIGHT- WOULD YOU
LIKE T CLOSE YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND. CALL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON. AYE
CALDERON AYE DAVIES YES DAVIES
I ARAMBULA. CHOI HI CHOI RA
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE STONE. THE
LIKUD DELIBERATE I WARD WARD
ALL RIGHT THE VOTED SIX TO ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO CHURN OR DO YOU WANT
TO. I DO WE STEP OUT ON SEPT
YES CALL FOR ADAMS. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO ARAMBULA.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE LORD LORD I
CURRENT VOTE. SEVENTY ZERO.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB EIGHT SIX
EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
TWO ZERO VILLUPURAM THE LOOK
WHAT I. CURRENT VOTE. SEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
THIRTY ONE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO FILOPODIA VILLA PUT I'D
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB FORTY SIX
CURRENT VOTERS FORTY ZERO
ARAMBULA. CHOI CHOI I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE WARD WORD I CURRENT
VOTE IS. SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB FORTY SEVEN CURRENT
VOTERS THREE TO ZERO ARAMBULA.
CHOI. SURE NOT VOTING GIPSON
GIPSON I'D WARD WORD ALL RIGHT
CURRENT VOTE. FIVE TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINETY TWO KERN VOTED THREE TO
ZERO ARAMBULA. CHOI CHOI ARA
GIPSON GIPSON IVILLAGE HOODA
THE LIPID II WARD WARD ALL
RIGHT CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE CURRENT VOTE
IS FORTY ZERO ARAMBULA. CHOI
CHOI I'D GIPSON GIPSON II WARD
LORD ARE A CURRENT VOTE.
SEVENTY ZERO. FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY ONE
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA. CHOI SORRY I CURRENT
VOTE.
SEVEN ZERO. SO WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE STATE FOR
TEN MORE MINUTES AND LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ASSEMBLY MAN
ARAMBULA SO IF ASSEMBLY MAN
ARAMBULA IS IN THE BUILDING-
AND- MR STOUT. FILE ITEM TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO ARAMBULA STONE
STONE I CURRENT VOTE. SEVEN
ZERO. THE FILE ITEM ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ONE
ARAMBULA STONE STONE I CURRENT
VOTE. SIX TO ONE. THANK. MARK.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO ARAMBULA A
REGULAR I FINAL VOTE EIGHT ZERO.
FILE ITEM TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE
ITEM NINE AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO TWO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I FINAL VOTE
SIX TO TWO. FILE ITEM TEN A. B.
FOUR NINE FOUR SEVEN NINE
CURRENT VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE FINAL
VOTE EIGHT ZERO. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ONE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE FINAL
VOTE SEVEN TO ONE. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB THIRTY ONE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT
TO ZERO. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FORTY SIX CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO ARAMBULA REGULAR I FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB FORTY SEVEN CURRENT
VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO ARAMBULA A
REGULAR HIGH. FINAL VOTE SIX
TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINETY TWO CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT ZERO. FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE CURRENT VOTE SEVENTY
ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB. FOUR SIXTY
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ZERO
ARAMBULA REGULAR I FINAL VOTE
EIGHT ZERO.